mark you're a chicago-based filmmaker
yes I'm from Chicago
born and raised we're about since
Chicago I'm from Englewood the Englewood
community in Chicago which is a is next
door to Hyde Park community which is
what the Obamas are from so Englewood as
you all know is a community that if you
hear about the media it's always the
negative presence coming out and some of
the people are you have our Derrick Rose
this from Englewood you have Bernie Mac
Jennifer Hudson and I'm sure we remember
that the things that happen with her her
family and that all took place in the
global community yeah what brings you to
Los Angeles so I'm here in Los Angeles
because of my family I can privilege
value one is screening at the
pan-african Film Festival and which has
been going on for 27 years and I'm you
know this is our sixth year attending
the festival yeah it's so I'm very I'm
very excited about it you come out every
year for it yes I do
Wow yes come on every year for the
festival what I have something in it or
not I'm supporting it yeah what do you
notice about the filmmaking community in
Chicago versus Los Angeles the energy or
whatever it is well and of course we
don't have as many filmmakers in Chicago
as we do in Los Angeles and the energy
like so in Chicago we're not deal with
the different filmmakers you know
they're they're always there on the
hustle this is always the hustles always
a grind trying to because here's the
thing the thing is in Chicago we're
dealing with investors you don't have a
lot of investors who are savvy when it
comes to investing in films opposed to
[ __ ] up opposed to LA and I'll let you
have more investors and investors are
more savvy because they understand the
film businesses a lot more Chicago is
different and so it brings about a
certain type of hustle or energy from
the filmmakers so in Chicago it's like
you know it becomes I talk to a lot of
filmmakers and they become frustrated
because they feel that they can't find
investors to invest in their project so
sometimes you have to like I tell them
like you have to go to LA
go to New York or go wherever to find
investors so in Chicago people want to
invest more into the real estate
business opposed in the field business
so the images in that aspect energy is
different and from just meeting someone
for let's say five ten minutes how can
you tell that they have that hustle and
that they seem like they do really want
to do all of the legwork and the grunt
work that most people don't want to do
versus maybe they just say they're a
filmmaker and they do make movies but
that hustle isn't there when they say I
need you to help me yes what someone
says I need you to help me do such and
such and such and such that kind of take
I'm kind of taken aback by that not
because I don't want to help anyone are
always I'm always looking to help people
however you have to be willing to put in
the work if you're putting it putting in
the work and you're out here at least
with a with a scrap boy you're out here
meeting different investors and you're
out here trying to get your project made
then that's a different that's totally
different so even if you go out you make
a film in the film it's crappy right at
least you're out here you make it
something but when you're not out here
trying to get things made and you say oh
I need help then that's kind of a
problem you're not because you know
because we all we all need help all of
us but we have to put in the effort we
have to put in the work and a lot of
people want more help or they want to be
helped more than they want to actually
put in the work so if you have put in
the work people will want to help you
you know and people are looking to happy
if you're here doing the work so I'm
kind of you know that's kind of the way
I look at things and know that if a
person is serious about their craft or
not so if someone come to say you know
look mark this is what I've done I've
done this I've done this and then I want
to do it wherever I have to do and
wanted to get you the help that you need
or bring in an investor or whatever I
need to help you get your go to the next
to that next level I'm gonna make it
happen because I know that you are here
actually working and making things
happen for yourself yeah do you think
that's part of the Midwest
work ethic cuz I have definitely seen
that people from the Midwest and
probably even East Coast there is a
little bit of a different work ethic no
having grown up in California basically
most of my life there does seem to be a
stronger work ethic you know those are
my words not yours so you know if anyone
was abashed and say california people
don't work hard they can they can come
at me but I have seen the difference a
little bit between from yeah the Midwest
definitely have a different idea about
work yeah I don't know because I know
this is what I do you know like me you
dealing with I mean particularly Chicago
because I'm from Chicago I I tend to see
there are filmmakers who make in they
may get mad angry at me descendants
we're making a lot of excuses
so as filmmakers and as artists we can't
make excuses you know we can't say well
this person is not helping me and we
can't say because my family I didn't get
into Sundance what we have to do is we
have to go out you know we have to just
start to do the work and so I don't want
to say that the work ethic is different
because people in LA you know you help
again you have more films that are being
made you have a lot of independent films
that being made in Chicago we don't have
a lot of independent films that I've
been made costly or consistently so I
don't know if if I can say that the work
ethic in LA among filmmakers is greater
than the work ethic in the middle what
film is in the Midwest No
again we talk about the Midwest so I
mean I don't know what's going on in
Detroit I don't know what's going on in
Michigan or in other parts of the
Midwest but as far as Chicago I know
that we're not being consistent enough
in making feature films to go into your
story a little bit more what businesses
did you start before you got into
filmmaking well I used to have a
cleaners and I just have a page of
business and because of the clearness in
the page of business there's always a
constant hustle and I always had to
market to paint my page of businesses
and my cleaners
so there's always that hustle always
that houses so to page a business and on
a cleaner
in the cleaners she tell me what that
like everyday what that was like what
like you're getting up in the morning
and what with the pager business what
are you doing so when I started to do
pages initially my brother got meant to
the page of business he had a page of
business that was very successful in
Chicago it was like it was like very
well-known very popular so I wanted to
get into the page of business because I
still have successful he was doing
financially and so what I would do is I
will go to his pager shop and I was bad
pagers and from banner pages I would go
and put it and put them in a briefcase
in cell phones put them in a briefcase
and I would go throughout the city of
Chicago and I was selling I would go to
different places and just sell the pages
and sound of the the telephones and I
will save the money and once I saved the
mining for to get a place my all store
then I opened my first store and then I
would say that money not open my second
store and I said this is you know
because the money kept because during
the 90s the pager pages were very hot
right and then from the pagers is when I
decided okay uh you know a young guy was
he was selling his cleaners I was like
okay and that was like the cleanest is
like right down the street from my home
I was like you know let me just try to
clean it the cleanup business so I went
in I purchased the cleaners business
from him and I had a cleaners
and so that's what got me yeah did you
know anything about the cleaner business
before not at all absolutely not I
didn't know anything about the page of
business I know we knew thinking about
the cleaning business at all so you kind
of just like on your feet
learn as you go it's kind of like put me
out there in the trenches I'll figure it
out
yes the same thing with filmmaking I
didn't go if I didn't go to film school
when I shot my first film I had
absolutely no idea of how to make a
movie and interesting story is yeah when
I shot my first film I shot everything
in a wide shot and so when I gave the
the footage over to the to my editor he
was like yo where your medium shot
senior close-ups so I learned I'm still
learning it's still a process and I
learned as I
along and so I applied that same energy
that I had in the page of business in a
cleaning business to the film business
do you have sort of a curiosity about
everything about how it works and you
enjoy figuring you know I enjoy freaking
it out yeah because if I buy I'm not the
type of person and this is what I tell
female filmmakers all the time it's just
go out there even if you feel like you
don't know it go out there and just do
it and you look you would learn you
learn you would freak it out you know
it's just on-the-job training because I
heard Spike Lee say one time that he
didn't feel like he was actually filming
and ting he did do the right thing and
when he did schooldays he was like he
had more toys to play with you know and
so with me is that as I go along
as I was going along and in a page of
business and the cleaning business in a
film business I learned I was kept
learning I'm still learning still under
process yeah well in your IMDB bio it
says that just do it the Nike slogan is
your favorite saying so it's gonna ask
you why what what what about that you
know just do it because I had a lot of
like when I do workshops in Chicago or
wherever I do workshops at I don't like
people they want to make films but
there's this block right and my thing is
get over that hurdle and just go out and
go and do it just make it happen
and again like if people see that you're
working and people see that you're doing
things people want to help they just
want to help if this is that you're
making an effort to do things you know
and if people if you do out here and
you're constantly constantly making
films for us and you have someone who
just doesn't want to help then you don't
bother about that person let them go
don't even think about don't even hard
hard on that on that person because a
lot of times we concentrate on the
negative and start concentrating on
those people who actually want to help
us so I say just do it just make it
happen do you need very little sleep I
could see you just being passionate
about something and it's like 3:00 in
the morning and you're like oh you know
what I better go to bed oh yes
I'm very passionate so even without did
the page of business and the clean of
business I always knew there was
something missing and I didn't know what
it was I always knew I wanted to write
and I didn't know what I want I met I
don't know whether you want to be plays
or books and then I stumbled into you
know the screenplays and and when I
started to the screenplays I had no idea
at all that I wanted to direct movies
you know so when I actually had no other
choice but to direct my own film is when
I found my true passion and so I mean
that's that's that's that's how it's
been so you're in LA to promote a film
yes
I'm in LA to promote my new film that
stopped like a preeminent value line
yeah and so it's screened today actually
before we have this interview yeah it's
great today we spread out the Cinemark
in Baldwin Hills at the mall was it the
air did you have a Q&A yes we did have a
Q&A it's interesting because a lot of
older people just one lady was like 88
years old who came out to the screening
and it was like it was filled with a lot
of older people in their 60s and 70s and
again like 180 was 88 years old and I
was very surprised because of Isis a
surprise but it it made me think because
this is this was our third screening
here we screen twice me screen yesterday
at miss me today and it was a much
younger crowd and today it was a much
older crowd and the feedback from the
older crowd was pretty different than
the feedback from the younger crowd
which I found to be very interesting but
but it's always gonna be like that as
family cuz we're gonna get you know
people going to view your work
differently you know which is good
therefore that you know they can sit
back and they can debate about it argue
about it and but we have to be open to
the criticism that we're going to get as
filmmakers of course because we put our
work out there that's another thing too
is that as filmmakers a lot of us we
make films and we feel that it's not
perfect so we don't want to show it to
anyone so if you feel that it's not
perfect that's the perfect time to show
because what happens is that you show it
to the audience and you listen to what
the criticism is and from those
criticism you go back into the
laboratory you make those adjustments
and you evolve that's how we evolve when
we grow like my first film again it's
the film that I shot everything in Y
shot everything I shot wide shots right
and so when I when I was getting hit
getting the constructive criticism I
went back I knew I had to continue to
study and so I think that's what we have
to do we have to always see ourselves on
the path and their students and always
studying I'm curious what did the
younger people ask forces the older
people okay so the older people one lady
said that this is this is a definitely a
project that we all should see in
particular in the black community
because we all know like what's going on
in the black community far as the
violence and things like that so she
figured you know and that she was like
you should show this in every black
community so the younger the young
yesterday I spoke with a much younger
woman and she was like this was a
difficult film to watch and I was like
what made it difficult I think so what
made it difficult she said because it's
hard to examine itself you know it's
hard to look at self and to examine
itself and so this is what the film does
is that it takes the black community it
takes us out of our but it's like outer
body experience right and for us to
examine the conditions that's going on
in our community and that's the thing
that was the difference between the
younger generation and then the older
generation because again the older
generation would to experience where you
know growing up where they may they may
leave their Mississippi or Alabama where
you know you have like people who owned
stores and things like that well the
younger people you know they didn't grew
up in that that time period where you
know black people control the economics
in the community so when you say okay
this is why this was violence and a
black community based like it's
difficult to watch it's difficult to
look at but opposed to it in 88 year old
ladies say okay we me
this in every black community so that
was the difference
did you ask some of the younger people
why they felt that yes because again the
reason why they felt that is because
again you know you know it's like some
people right we like like we like to
it's difficult to do a self-examination
they point the finger saying this is why
certain things happen so it's easier to
blame
place the blame on others opposed to no
matter what it is you know no matter
what it is to place the blame on others
instead of just looking at doing the sex
stuff examination and saying okay this
is how I'm going to correct myself so a
lot of people a lot of us really don't
want to correct self we want to just you
know you know place blame on others
instead of just correct yourself
so from having those early businesses
Pedro business drycleaners etc what did
that teach you about like filmmaking so
the thing is because of as filmmakers
where a lot of those want to be artists
and a lot of us don't want to deal with
the business aspect which is cool if you
don't what you have to write if you
depend on other people to take care of
the business aspect you will always be
broke so we have to understand business
we have to understand marketing because
we have to apply those things not just
meet just be artists we have to Apollo
stage so if you look at some of the most
successful filmmakers from Tyler Perry
to George Lucas to Steven Spielberg
they're not only great filmmakers but
they're also a great businessman so as a
businessman I took those same that same
energy those those same laws and I just
transfer those laws and that imaging and
I the hustle to the film business so I
knew when I went out to me even again
I'm gonna just use my first film as an
example even the first film that I made
I knew I shot everything we shot in
washout but I was like I didn't give up
I didn't say okay I'm not I'm not going
to put it out I'm gonna say that I'm not
I don't want it to edit it I was like go
ahead just put it together
so we did still put it together and out
what I did was I just like I went out
with the briefcase with the pages I got
copies of the DVDs made and I went out
and hustle those DVDs it was going
door-to-door it was going hitting the
streets of Chicago it was going to
different clubs and you just use that
same energy and that's those same laws
and transform those over to the movie
business which allowed me to continue to
make films for the last 15 years being
is because of that drive that hustle and
understanding the business aspect of
filmmaking so can you take me through a
day of like selling DVDs what that was
like oh yes so what I would do is I
would go for a first I would I would had
it I always would get like a thousand
copies made and I would say okay I I
knew that I had to do an event so what I
would do is I would do an event and I
would do like a poetry even right and I
was surrounding the poetry vendors say
okay $25 for the poetry event so I would
hire poets I would have like food and
but a DVD will come in with that as well
so I wrapped everything around the
selling of this of my movies and then
what I would do is I would get up in the
morning like if I when I hit the streets
I get up in the morning you know get
dressed and put my DVDs a box of DVDs in
the car and I was just going like a busy
street like say for instance 87th and
Ashley this is like a really really
major busy street and I was stand up in
front in the middle of the street with
the DVDs as Carl's driving past and sell
the DVDs you know and people will stop
and they were like okay whose movies
this is my movie my name is Mark Harris
I would like you know wanna know if you
like you know to my DVD and a lot of
time not a lot of times most times
people were like oh okay
they want they want to support you even
if they don't watch the film they want
to support you because they seem that
you out here you out here making it
happen you know so I said today it's a
lot easier because so much because we're
streaming you can put your family on
YouTube and you know how to you
and people will watch it but with me it
was like I went out hit the streets
I went door-to-door when I went
door-to-door people will come and say
what were you doing my my name is Mark
Harris I'm a filmmaker from Chicago I
would like you know just know like for
you to know what about my DVD what is it
about I will tell them the story line
and it was like okay some people say no
but some people say yeah but every day I
will go back I will go back I would hit
different blocks up you know even if
they say you know you go back maybe a
week later you know you know most times
most times people were bad because the
otoscope this person is serious you just
can't take no for an answer at all and
that's how that was our day to day just
going out hitting the streets going
door-to-door going to the clubs and just
selling your DVDs selling my DVDs would
you say you're an extrovert no I'm a
little introvert okay yeah because that
takes a real like confidence or you know
special kind of person to be able to go
and be like this self driver and knock
on people's doors and that's scary yeah
it is but it is interesting because like
when I'm like around a lot of people
event I'm if I'm not this is what my
wife says a lot she says when I'm on the
set I mean she visits me on the said she
and she doesn't like visiting me come to
coming to the set for this very reason
it she said I'm a different person and
I'm like and I said what do you mean I'm
a different person she said well like
you just a totally different person me
you want to say opposed to me you at
home you know and so like if I'm just if
I'm not doing anything fin related and
it feels like a party I'm like sit back
observant but if I have to do something
feel related onset or then I'm more open
you know more extrovert you know and but
when again when I went out to with those
DVDs it's overcoming your fear and a lot
of us and I think that's the key thing
is that a lot of us don't want to share
our because they fear what people may
say a lot of us don't want to go door to
door because they fear that people will
say no you know a lot of us don't want
to start on that first screenplay
because they fear people will not
or people like they would not get it
made or you know so their fear is the
one it sucked it just controls us so we
have to overcome that fear and so it
means that I had to overcome it was the
fear was there it was there like going
you know I was timid you know especially
going you know especially when I was
doing like the the pages and because
I've never done that before so when I
did the pagers and why did the going and
asking people to buy pages again that
was just I was just shopping in my
scales for when I had to do the DVD
which it was what I was most passionate
about but we have to go get over that
fear and just go out and just do it and
make it happen
just do it yeah so with the film that
you went door to door with that was your
first film that was my first okay and it
was at a documentary no it was it was a
it was a narrative oh it's called
Wyman's Waimea cheap okay and of course
that's a catchy to a subject sure yeah
yeah I'm sure and so did a distributor
pick up the film that's the only film
that I've ever made I have it I have no
never got distribution for at all and
that's that was the one that was that
you know my first film again and that's
the one of the ones that allowed me to
get enough make enough money to make
other films but I never got a
distribution for that family that's the
only family this was in 2005 this was a
2005 okay yeah so you're knocking on
people's doors in the Chicago area
selling them a film about infidelity and
some people are like yeah I'll take it
yeah beautiful
no I don't want to see it or what what
would they say well so well because the
cat does this they were like what what
is that what is the film about a lot of
women would say why do men cheat so the
conversation okay and that's a key thing
to is that people don't don't be so
quick to just want to get people's money
have that in business there
how about genuine conversation with
people and talk with people and when you
just so quick to get their money they
gonna like no they know they're not
gonna want to support you but if you
have a sincere conversation with people
and you just listen to people
and give them be honest with people you
can get their support so when I will go
door to door
a lot of women be like why do man she
like maybe like me are you telling our
secrets alright so the women want women
of course they want to know why do you
manage change so we have that discussion
you know in uh in it would it would you
know we have that discussion and then
they were about it they were about a DVD
and the more you have that discussion
here's the thing and more you help or
you talk you have a discussion you
listen to what they are saying and you
answer the questions honestly they're
gonna they're going about it because
they want to know what this movie is
about and they want to know the secrets
of the reasons why why men cheat
did anyone ever ask you to do one from
the female perspective no I've never
been asked to do really oh why women
cheat I don't know just just to kind of
do like you you doing black and
privilege volume one so you could do you
know I don't know yeah that we good job
you're great you know I think that would
be a great topic to cover the reason why
women cheat yeah even more taboo yeah
cuz then for men because women cheat
different for different reasons of
course sure yeah sure I'm sure did you
find that there was one reason for me
men or was it was it various reasons but
it was just a need that wasn't met
whether it was sexual or emotional very
different reasons my man cheat I mean
like I mean just be honest like we
really do we really need a reason I
don't for me me a women like my
emotional attached that's why when again
that's why when uh when we found out
that the woman that recent agree that we
love cheated on us we'd be devastated we
could be out there cheating
Oh doing everything all kind of thing
but we found out that a woman she didn't
know knows we're devastated we
heartbroken you know we're so
unforgiving you know and so I think that
would be a great subject to tackle as
far as uh why do women she
well you know you see it in the media -
and then we'll move on from this topic
but then if a man does it it's it's a
little more forgivable okay he's a man
and she threw you know quote threw
herself at him or whatever but if a
woman does it it's it's Wow
like who is she she's but she's a bad
person you know so it's just interesting
how its pristine you know you know back
in the day you know these indiscretions
they would call you know and but yeah
it's just interesting how it's perceived
yeah so we'll move on okay so how many
of those DVDs did yourself okay so we
were selling like DVDs for we got a we
got the first the first one we did a run
of like a thousand we saw those got
another run of like another thousand so
we got a total runs like I think like
5,000 however we would sell a lot for
10,000 me for $10 sometimes we would do
two for ten or things like that so we
told we saw over over the years maybe
like between pretty close to 10,000 DVDs
yeah yeah but this is over over time
yeah were you ever tempted because I
know to get those DVDs made weren't
probably we're not cheap if you got
unless you did like a huge bulk is I
still remember the calls oh okay yeah so
I would get a thousand made and would be
like $1,100
oh yeah $1,100 for a thousand it was a
company car I don't know if they're
still in business Moses Duplin him and
when we do go to now they will print us
a thousand copy they would mail at me i
all these big boxes in in my room that
was just like cuz i at that particular
time i live in the attic of my mom's
house okay
and and so i would get these dvds and
they would make me ship it would come to
our house and I would just have all
these boxes of DVDs and attic when I
lived and but I was spending like you
know a thousand dollars for a thousand
copies like he level hundred dollars for
a thousand copies were you ever tempted
to buy a huge like even more or were you
afraid that somehow you
be able to sell them out or you just
wanted to do it in certain increments I
wanted to do them a thousand each
because I knew but before I actually
here's the thing before I actually sold
the DVDs I already knew like how to get
rid of at least 300 and that is what I
was telling about is I would do events
like I would do it a poetry event and
where I would sell the tickets for $25
where you know when you get poetry you
get it food and you get a DVD so I knew
that I knew that based of that dollar
amount that I was going to least make my
thousand dollars back plus a profit
where I can reinvest and then from there
what I can do is because I wanted to
people to get the DVD I can I can sell
the DVD for five dollars you know or I
can just sell it off somebody say okay I
don't have the money at this particular
time
can I pin you back you know so you have
to take that chance okay you know give
them a DVD give them a DVD and something
a lot of times like when people say that
you know they don't have the money I
really don't have the money if you give
them the movie and then come back they
may even give you a $20 bill and that
happened as well the movie was ten
dollars and I would give I was like you
know we're about it you know just take
the DVD and they will come back and then
give me a $20 $20 so those things you
know so we can't you know we want to
because that my mission was to get the
movie out get the movie out so but I
knew I had to make that investment back
so you knew if I do this only this
amount I feel confident that I can get
them out yes oh yeah your nickname is
Dino do you know how did you get I
believe from the flip my sister I had my
sister her name is Coco okay Flis
dollars yeah so Dino is like like if
someone calls me Dino I know that's
that's the one from way back then when I
was growing up all my mom you know my
mom she calls me Dino
my brothers and sisters my cousins they
all call me Dino or anybody that's a
friend and calls me do you know there's
someone I grew up with yeah
Englewood Chicago is Chicago okay and so
when did you start the Film Festival
there we started in 2007 years ago which
will be 2010
so we 20 2010 is when we had a
ribbon-cutting event and we screamed
like my old films we did the
ribbon-cutting event and then the next
year was off first the first festival
and then where we have film festivals
from films from all over the country
that came in and one of the things that
we did was I wanted to get because it
was very important for us to especially
when we knew filmmakers from different
parts of the world were coming in to
screen it - today - the screening is to
make sure that we packed out the theater
so what we would do over over the lowest
period of time is we would give tickets
away we would work with different
organizations within the England work
community and what they would do is that
they would give out tickets to the
different residents in Englewood and
that's how we were able to continue to
pack the theaters but again you know it
was we had to pay for the theater we had
to pay for travel and things like that
because we know we want to bring the
family Kazaam bringing guests there so
it got pretty expensive but we want to
bring it back in the dish year or next
year we definitely want to bring the
festival back yeah how many seats did
you have to fill 300 300 it was like the
total was to be exact it was like 297 at
the it was like the ice the air and
another thing too is that Englewood
there's no there's no actual movie
theater there so we had to do - you know
the actual screening on the films and
the Chatham area which is kind of next
door to Englewood but we did our
workshops we do workshop and all of our
workshops and panels all of those things
were free and are free to the community
and so but we kept those things in
Englewood
like at the library or at the local
schools so we kept those things in our
community so start from your love of
film and storytelling why was it
important to you to do this community
based film festival because I knew that
if you look at the Englewood community
you know we know most people we hear
about the violence in Chicago and I'm
sure like like whenever I travel no
matter where I try to throw out this
forth not just the country well
throughout the world I go to Belize I
chose to Belize a lot but people people
always talk about when you tell me from
Chicago they talk about the violence in
Chicago so they make you think that you
know you come out and it's like doing
the Al Capone days and people get shot
up which is not true and so what was
important to me was is to change the the
image of the Englewood community and
what better way to do it we know we know
as filmmakers right we know how how the
media how film how music how
entertainment is a very very powerful
tool so what we wanted to do is just use
the the Film Festival
you want to use the films by by doing
the workshops by screening and positive
films and positive content to use that
to change the image of the evil
community so that was that's always been
our objective that's still our objective
is to change the image of the Inuit
community yeah have you always been an
optimist
you see seem like a positive person from
short time I've met you here and our
email exchanges I know you had a nice
saying in your email it just gives it an
impression that you you know you're
positive and you're open to to just
different input from other people oh
yeah you have to be I think a big
mistake that is why I think right now
this because especially as filmmakers
right because we control like filmmakers
we have so much control which we really
don't understand the power that we have
so when you go to the movies right a lot
of it you know we said trans
you know if you look at boys and hula if
you look at Minister society you look at
good fellows right people like even
rappers right rappers take their names
off of movies or off of gangsters from
different movies because we're what we
do is so powerful you know and so I know
that as a filmmaker I have to have to be
positive because if I don't then what
I'm doing is I'm just aiding in the
destruction of humanity and I never
wanted to be involved in that I always
wanted to say I want to stay positive
I'm gonna put that positive content and
I've been offered for so many times to
do negative things I'm like no I'm not
gonna do that
and so as filmmakers we just have to be
true to us and be true but we just can't
do things just for money because at the
end of the day we doing things or we
just can't be in this business for money
because we'd be doing things and we
won't be said of our souls won't be
satisfied you know what we we may be
passionate about filmmaking but if
you're if you're taking your passion if
you're doing things that you don't want
to do you losing your soul so I always
wanted to be positive I always want to
be put our positive content am I'm
always positive know there's something
that of course not because I'm human
sure you know and so again what I always
have to even remind myself like this is
what I mean it's always been tempting
you know it's always been Ted because
you know especially when you're in a
position when you you know you have to
pay your bills and it's how it happens
you have to pay those bills and somebody
calls with an offer but an offer that's
not that's gonna challenge you morally
you know and you have to say no I can't
do that you know there was no chances
you know those are things I've had to
turn down because of that I'm not just
gonna put out any any type of images and
things like that because we arty know as
you know we have we have a duty as
filmmakers and I do it is you know first
we have to be true to us if
you want if you want to bend his
business to make money go ahead be in
his business to make money
you know if there's plenty money to be
made but how are we what are we at the
end of the day 10 years from now 20
years from now you know what I mean what
are we how are we going to change the
condition of this world you know and so
many times people people just want to
stop labels on people we don't want to
really have true real dialog so I
started having true real dialog we just
put labels on people which is which is
very unfortunate yeah and I think we're
more divided now and in recent few years
and and it's not just politically but
just in many different ways and and it's
it's it's definitely a parent you know
no I've read articles too that you know
we were just more divided and beliefs or
or you know and it's it's it's a shame
because you you would think that just
with you know social media and and
everybody's access to the same tools
that there would be sort of an evolution
where we could just be I don't everybody
would be sort of satisfied with their
own life because they can put something
out there whatever their passion is and
and not think that they have to wait for
someone to quote help them but yeah I
definitely see that and I see in the
comments - I don't know if you can see
in other videos comments and just how
divided we are right now yes would you
say you've always been a positive person
or or like this sort of open thinker or
or did something happen in life that
kind of changed you in that direction I
think I have all I think this is this is
this is why I love my mother so much
like my mother is a die-hard Christian
point-blank she goes to church every
Sunday but she never forced any type of
religion on us and I never told you this
but she never forced us to go to church
she never forced religion on us so I
think that had a lot to do with being a
critical thinker and then when I would
ask questions I remember when I was when
I was I hate the Bell
have you know eight years old and I I
had asked the pastor a question the
church I want to and he told me never to
questioning God and I was like but I was
young and I knew that something is wrong
here you're like why would not why would
God would not want us to question him
you know if he's secure in his word so
but my mom so I always always been a
critical thinker and from since I can be
since I can remember
and I never try to rush into judgment
you know like ever trying to rush into
job I have to think about like when
things happen on social media I'm I'm
not the person to just post or repost
off I have to research it to see is this
stuff is real you know is this like even
even even when President Donald Trump
tweets and people share his tweets I
have to go to this page and see okay is
this a real tweet you know and so we
have to search out things and to make
sure that things are actually like even
as especially as filmic is because we
are storytellers we shall always
research something before we just put it
out there you know because again we we
hold so much power like artists hold so
much power so you know we're very
familiar with how China changed because
of their artists you know China was a
country that was you know and with them
you know OPM and the prostitution but
what they did was they they put that
birthday artist together they said this
is what we're gonna do we want to use
art we will use entertainment to change
the condition of the Chinese people and
look at China now as a superpower you
know and so as artists right as artists
what we can do is but we have to come
together and we have to cuz you know we
have to come together and we have to
start using our gifts and our talents to
change good we can change not only
America but we can change the entire
world if we just start to put out more
positive content you know content that
show more people to the content that
shows love
concept that shows more unity more
respect
you know goddess of what we believe in
you know just respect people's ideas as
filmmakers you know that should be very
important for it important to us just to
show you know just to do more positive
because the thing is is that you have so
many so much stuff that's so negative
that the people are looking for more
positive content now again let me
explain to you
it's the interesting thing so we hear
all the time how black films do not sell
overseas which is totally false this is
what people are looking for and you know
what I can't approve that this false but
what we have done with our independent
films we so we have sold a lot of
independent a lot of my films overseas
this is what people are not interested
in overseas they're not interested in
the negative images that as black
filmmakers that we put out if we put out
positive images positive story I get so
many emails from people from Europe
people from different parts of America
it just said that thank you like we did
a film called black coffee and it's a
couple of sites called it one of the
most positive black films ever made
right we get so many people who just
emailed us and inbox us through social
media just thanking us for putting out
not just not talking about black people
I'm talking about people from all across
all walks of life thanking us for
putting out positive a positive message
in a positive images and this is what
people want to see they want to see more
positive content and it's not that they
don't want it's not that black films
don't sell overseas but they don't want
to see the negative energy the negative
images they want to see positive images
cuz you know leave the negative images
when you want to leave them at but more
people want to see the more positive
stuff and if we show the more positive
images of black people you know as black
filmmakers then those fingers would do
very well overseas they don't they don't
want that type of stuff you know in a
shouldn't they shouldn't have to
we shouldn't have to give it all you
know we should you know so just that
today did you always feel this way I
mean did you go through a phase where as
a teenager let's say you liked certain
films but then you realize you know what
I'm not feeling how people are
represented in these movies see when I
came up I came up I was a big John use
fan from Chicago love John I used to sit
back and watches watch his films and
study his films and one of the things is
I love the storyteller I love those love
stories I can relate to those stories so
coming up those are the type of films
that I was influenced by you know
various likely to come along you know
more up you know and it's early and
stuff so many positive images so now
again I love me some good fellows I love
I mean I love mark Scorsese I love
martin scorsese you know so I look at me
I look at those fails but I always knew
you know but again like my favorite
filmmakers like the JA use my favorite
uh you know Spike Lee's and I love Kevin
Smith - I know a lot of you know a lot
of people talk about you know some of
his films and how you know but if we
watch carefully watched Kevin Smith's
films he sent some really deep stuff in
his films you know especially dogs but
all this was like his Dogma is like one
of my favorite films you know so yeah I
mean you know so but sometimes sometimes
here like even with if you just take
Dogma for example like Kevin Smith's
family Kevin Smith gives you his films
like they're wrong there's a lot of
profanity in them but just listen to
what they're saying there's something a
message that speaks but he's saying that
we can like for the people for a certain
type of generation so he's giving you -
he's giving it to you rob but he's also
putting something in it that you could
take and making you think cuz dogmas
great that's amazing film yes funny cuz
he speaks like that - yeah you know he
may be funny and sarcastic but there's
like a point to what he's trying to make
yeah yeah I love this interview yeah
yeah it's very entertaining yes we'll go
back to your first film why men cheat in
2005 so how did that movies success
impact you
getting your next film project off the
ground yeah so it was it was a it was a
while my first time that ever that I
ever got distribution for was a film
called black butterfly it was a film we
made for less than $10,000 and he won
actually put that film out
we know IVA is a major major company but
it got me Ellen Blackwell was he solved
the trailer I said the train he said I
want this film but before then we did we
did a film called getting my first film
why men cheat I used to love her
highlight you hit me with those films
those films are the films that you know
from why men cheat we took that money
and we invested in the to Harlequin hit
me we take that money invest in it I
used to love her and we did I used to
love her that feeling right there is
screening we did that film for $3,500 it
was in like 10 film festivals and when I
went to the film festivals I didn't just
go there just a screening film when I
would go to our house DVDs made up I
wasn't even thinking about honestly I
wasn't even thinking about distribution
I was just thinking about selling DVDs
and it wasn't until we came and did
black butterfly is when you know I said
okay if I have to if I have to release
this film on my own then I would do that
but what we did was we are we are I said
the trailer to I sent the trailer to
Allen Blackwell ie one he said I want
that film and then from that film then
we got distribution for how let you hear
me then we got because of the success
that I found and so what happened was
with black butterfly is e1 bit like the
first week they had to reprint death row
they have to print more DVDs up because
they're all sold out in the stores it
was in Walmart and they all sold out so
it had to rush and print more out
because I told her I was like look I
have an audience out there and what
we're going to do is we want to promote
this film we're gonna promote this film
so you all have to print out more I
think they print out 5000 copies the
first time which I understand I mean
they want to be safe and so like the
first like the first week
those were all gone and there because of
the success of black butterfly is is
when we got distribution for I used to
love her then we got distribution for
heart of you hit me and from from the
success of that one fail it's so you
made it for $10,000
oh one that was in Walmart yes it was it
was like the ninety five hundred and how
many locations did you have we had a
total of I think like eight locations
yeah a location but this this is how we
were doing we were shoot the way we
shoot this film when we shoot on
weekends because people work so we were
shooting on weekends Buchwald and we
would take one day so we would shoot a
12-hour day on a Saturday and Sunday I'm
gonna Friday what we would deal with
this when we just take one thing and we
just shoot that thing and we just you
know and that's how we got to film a oh
like a six it was like six weeks and uh
yeah so that's how you were able to keep
it solo that's why we were able to keep
it solo and also this is the secret the
secret is you have to work with you have
to work with I know it is difficult in
LA because we talk about locations
because people are familiar with how
much is you how much money they pay
people pay for locations when Chicago is
pretty different
so in Chicago for us is that you know I
always shoot up like a lot of the film
was shot at my mom's house I shot some
of this film at my aunties house you
know and a lot of the stuff we not
exterior stuff you know where we don't
need we don't need any permits to set up
or we would go to a park and shoot like
the park that we shot at is a park that
I grew up in like playing basketball and
baseball and things like that so we
would go to that Park and we shoot
things so we didn't really put a lot of
money for locations at all because we
use friends and families locations and
that's another thing we should do you
know just look at your friends I should
friends as far as like you know can you
cheat at their home you know and try to
do it you like say for instance if you
shoot at someone's home you know just be
respectful of their home maybe donate
you know donate $100 $150 towards the
electricity you know and
I know in LA is kind of expensive in
locations are very expensive but you
know just like give you shooting
somewhere else you know just ask the
person if you can just you know shoot
there you know and they open to it what
do you think is the best way for a
filmmaker who's made a movie let's say
cost $20,000 to make that money back in
today so probably not with DVDs as much
maybe I don't know I think the best way
for filmmakers to make a movie if they
made a movie for $20,000 to make that
movie back is a furnace if the budget is
$20,000 we not rent out theaters right
so safer means they keep the price very
low so if you if you ran a theater I
know in Chicago I can write out a
300-seat theater for like $800 if you do
that four or five times you made your
money back you know and then what you
want to do is you want to you want you
always want to make sure that we're
doing your marketing try to do more more
so to us social media because it's free
you want Instagram you know your
Facebook you want LinkedIn so target
target those your audience there and do
group pages and things like that and so
make sure that like try to sell the
tickets for like $10 you know 10 to 12
dollars don't try to go $20 because it's
easier to get 10 or 12 I've got a person
than $20 and people with people again it
will support you and don't get
frustrated and I think a big mistake as
we as filmmakers what our frustration
comes in that is that we look for
friends we look from support from our
friends and our family don't do it the
people who are going to support you are
the people or like your people that you
don't know like lawyers doctors school
teachers firemen police officer those
people think everyone loves movies so so
go to those people you know but we want
to you want to market towards other
filmmakers no don't do that
don't other females going to support you
if they want to support you and don't
get frustrated with other filmmakers
don'ts why we why are we promoting to
other filmmakers those are not the
people that's not our audience our
audiences people who are not filmmakers
people who just want entertainment those
are the people that you market to like
people who have no interest at all in a
film business you know and then what
happens is that those people are going
that crowd like give you a perfect
example when Tyler Perry started to
build his his empire he didn't he didn't
market to us other filmmakers or other
play writers he marketed towards the
church and those church people they
weren't enter and they just want
entertainment you know when he built the
Empire because of people who just wanted
to sit down at place they didn't want to
be actors they want to be directors they
don't want to be producers this is
digits one entertainment so there was a
lot of people that he was marking it
toward too so that's that's what we have
to do as well so I know I had a lot of
filmmakers get frustrated and say you
know I don't get the support well
because you're marking it to the wrong
people
market to those people again to the
fireman to the police officers to the
teachers to the janitor to just everyday
normal human being who doesn't want
anything at all to do with the film
business but to enjoy a movie so that's
our audience it's a little tricky here
because a lot of people do these dual I
mean there's people that work you know
in all facets of LA and then they're
also an actor on the side or what you
know they're going on gameshow auditions
and then they're a fireman by day or
whatever you know so there's some you
know but I hear what you're saying and I
find that very interesting that you said
not to friends and family or or let's
say college alumni or whatever it's so
can you talk about did you did you have
to learn that the hard way I'd be okay
oh yes nothing this is all true that
Charlie terrible Oh like my first film
you know my first film like I would you
know go to I will text my friends and I
would takes my family members as far as
tickets I was like okay this is not
working you know so what I would do is
I will go another thing what I would do
is I would get a Chicago we call them
pluggers I guess you are called like
pluggers or which are like flyers
oh we call them and Chicago we call them
pluggers so they're like you know copy
the DVD with all the information on
there and I will go to the different bus
stops so in Chicago I'm sure they have
them here people drive and they park
their cars in these lots and they take
the train and work and but they would do
this in the south suburbs so so the
people out in the south suburbs what
they are coming to the city these you
have all these different Lots so I would
get like ten thousand Flyers made up and
when I would go in doing that time when
they network I would put the flags on
their cars you know that's how we work
you know
those are the people that our head but
it was because I already knew I but it
takes me a long time to find out that
you just can't promote to your friends
your family and other filmmakers
but most of the people the people not
you know your friends not you know cuz
they're gonna they're gonna support you
they're gonna support you you know you
shouldn't mean you should we should have
to force them to support us right so we
have to force them you want somebody to
people who are going to sincerely and
genuinely want to support you you know
not to support you but you want them
that's going to come out because the
entertainment is good the quality is
good and so those are the people that we
want out of the saying um no man's a
prophet in his own land is I don't know
if that's a biblical reference okay and
my grandmother used to tell it to me so
but it basically means that like outside
of your social circle you can actually
be perceived as doing more and
you'reyou're whatever you're working on
is viewed in a different different light
than within your own social circle or
your sort of peer group because they're
like oh wow we know this person so it's
just view differently yes and and I
think I think that's something a lot of
artists deal with whatever whatever
they're doing and so your your work is
perceived differently from outsiders who
don't know you versus people maybe you
went to school with
or friends or whatever because they're
like oh we get we know mark but or you
know we know Karen or whatever you know
but it's different when it's a stranger
because then they say oh you're a
filmmaker oh okay you know I think it's
just different here's the reason I
believe is the reason why a lot of us a
lot human beings period right a lot of
us we really don't believe in ourselves
so it's hard to believe that a person
that we know can actually make it or
succeed in life and because a lot of us
give up on our dreams and our goals in
life and you know whatever whatever what
we want to do and to actually know
someone that's that's uh that's out
there pursuing their dreams and out
there pursuing their goal not saying
that there's envy of course whenever
their success there there's always going
to be people are envious of successful
people that comes with the territory but
a lot of us don't believe that we can
actually know somebody that successful
because we don't think much of ourselves
if we think highly of ourselves and we
value ourselves then we know that our
friend can be successful our friend can
be successful because we know that we
could be successful so it's like you
know and we're working one another where
we are we're pushing one another and
that's what's what's missing across the
board is that we're not working together
and we're not encouraging I know I was
looking at a documentary with uh it was
about I want to say Steven Spielberg
documentary on Netflix and Brian DePalma
was saying how when when when he was
shooting Scarface Steven Spielberg Marsh
Scorsese will come up to the set when he
was shooting and they would watch his
they would have his back so if he's
missing something he's missing shots or
whatever they will let him know look
they were they were they were have his
back they were watch his back and these
are someone like Marco says George Lucas
Davis Bert the most successful film
makers probably ever because here I see
these guys who worked
and they made sure look this is my
friend I'm gonna make sure my friend I
look out for my friend you know and this
is what we're missing like you know just
going ons on a set and you know that
your your your fellow filmmaker is is
making a movie just sitting back and
really you know it's just observant if
you see something that's out of place
then you you know look this is our place
so that's what they did you know and we
can't you know we today we take that
kind of take that those type of things
from branding you know do you think
that's a symptom of our times or do you
think that's just human nature that some
of us aren't hardwired not that we don't
want to help people but some people
they're just super competitive by Nature
and it doesn't matter if they're friends
family whoever they've got to be like
the top dog and they don't want that
place challenged that's that's the day
yeah that's today because that's why a
lot of people okay so here's the thing a
lot of people we were in a third
position we want to hold on to that
position because a lot of us are you
know okay a lot of us are selfish
we don't we feel that the Sun is only
able to shine on us meaning that there
are seven billion people on this planet
right there's enough room for all of us
to have an audience there's enough room
for the sun is shining on all of us
because the Sun does shine on all of us
equally you know so when we're in a
position of power right and we know we
see somebody that's our Hill just doing
it constantly doing it how can we just
sit back and not I know we dealt with
this this thing helped early on but not
even I'm not gonna use the term help but
just reach down and say okay I'm gonna
I'm gonna pull you up and I'm gonna give
you a not give because if you I had
working that's something you earn you
know you make you know that's something
you are like you know and we're gonna
we're gonna make sure that you're taking
care of because you know if I have if I
have a bowl of soup I want to make sure
that you have half and I'm gonna suit
and that's how we stay consistent I said
we stay
on top and that's how we you know and we
just just happen to happen each other
just happy working working with one
another I hate to use the term help but
working with one another to make sure
that you know where all of us are eating
all of us are on top and everyone is
allowed to express their ideas and work
their passion and their dreams and if
everyone is successful and this is but
it's no mistake that Steven Spielberg
and George Lucas and Brian Department my
school say it's not isn't there's no
mistake that over 40 years that these
guys still I don't know talk they're
still gonna talk it's not by accident
they have one elbow out they work with
one another
and they looked out for one another do
you think that the ability to and we
won't use the word help again
but I don't know if it's okay maybe it's
altruism and the term of just not not
wishing somebody negativity or trying to
sabotage something because there's
plenty of that in the world do you think
that's the mark of a successful person
is someone that's not as quick to
sabotage it seems like there's a lot of
that in a lot of spheres a lot of
circles yeah is that human nature I
don't I don't think it's human nature to
sabotage I don't know I think is human
nature to help or to like you see
somebody is doing something and you know
because we by nature I believe believe
by nature we want other people to to to
to make it but if something is something
in us that's like nah man I have to do
this by myself or oh I just have to have
the right or the right on me so I don't
I don't think is I don't think people
with you you do have people who
purposely sabotage other people because
you know I just have to have but at the
end of the day they I don't I don't
believe that they're gonna stay on top
lab for a long time you know I'm talking
about 30 40 50 years maybe they may do a
period of five years you know especially
when you cuz you know it's all is going
to eventually come back you know it's
gonna eventually come back but I don't
think people like that is
tough alone there's no longevity in it
at all three things you wish you'd known
before you made your first feature film
oh my god you know three things I wish
I'd known before I made my first feature
film
I wish out all right let me say this I
think because I didn't know anything I
didn't know anything at all about
filmmaking like I'm glad everything
happened the way it did because I think
had out this is me I think because I
didn't know a lot it made me want to
improve so many people wrong
improvement you know just let people
know like look I can do this I can do
this and the way I got into the film
business is I'm not different business
but into directing was actually I don't
want to say by accident but it was it
was there was a director who promised
that you know I write all these
screenplays and he promised that the
screenplay that option to him will be
the next screenplay that he write he
didn't go through with his work and at
that particular time I was emotional
about it
I was angry about it but what I did was
I went out and I made my first film yeah
as I look back I'm thankful that he said
no cuz hey he made that first film I
would never probably get on the set and
start to direct but once I got on set to
direct my first film even though I
didn't know anything I don't know
anything about filmmaking I didn't know
what I was doing I knew that this is
what I wanted what I wanted to do so I
don't think that's anything that I wish
I had of known because you know at that
particular time I could say well I wish
I had went to film school but I don't
wish I had want to film school because I
love I love that whole process of
learning as I go along
learning as I make different films in
because it for me for me making it my it
was like I was film school for me and
every time I was I was screen the film I
would get this constructive criticism
not only did it make me a better
filmmaker but that criticism made me a
better human being that I probably
wouldn't have received have had I went
to film school so as I as I got that
criticism I didn't go I didn't think I
would do everything I had to listen so
when you listen to in able to accept
constructive criticism that does
something to you to your character you
know so a lot of us again a lot of us
don't want to display our work because
of that of that constructive criticism
you know so there's no I don't think
that's anything that I I wish I hadn't
known I'm going to going to you know I
don't think there's anything I'm blessed
to have to the road that I took as far
as as a filmmaker I mean there's
something to be said sometimes for not
researching something and just trying it
as long as it's not life-threatening
because sometimes then you talk yourself
out of it mm-hmm and you go oh well if I
do this and it's not this then this is
gonna happen and so sometimes maybe it's
better to just say like you said just do
it and then you kind of learn as you go
and and with your first film you said it
was all wide-shots
you didn't have any close-ups or mediums
and so but if you had been to like
Precious about it you maybe you wouldn't
have made the first one and then it
wouldn't have led to the second one I
mean I'm just theorizing here I don't
see the thing is is that I think if I
went to film school I probably would
have thought okay I can't make a film
for 5,000 oh if that first film it was
made for like a thousand dollars I would
like I can't make a film for a thousand
dollars you know because in primary film
school I don't know maybe they're taught
that you need a certain budget but I
wasn't thinking about budget I wasn't
thinking about I thought okay I don't
know I can make a sale for $5,000
I know I could make a film for $10,000
so head I want to film school I probably
didn't have that I probably didn't think
that way I probably
okay I need 150,000 to make a film
during that particular time you know and
so that's why I'm saying I'm thankful
that I went in that direction because
you know hey I'm saying I have a
thousand dollars cause I'm gonna make a
movie you know and uh even though it
shot it was everything we shot in wide
shots mom I'm grateful I'm thankful you
know because the next one we had a
medium shots we had a wide shots we're
not close-ups and then you know and you
know each each project you know I've
seen it you know grow and grow and grow
I'm gonna go get you know I'm always I
consider myself a student filmmaker
because I'm always learning I'm watching
my favorite I'm watching the interviews
I'm always cuz I've always considered
myself a stand filmmaker and I would
never ever escape that good plug thank
you for just one more time and no I'm
kidding thank you so you live in Chicago
you're here in LA screening a film at
the pan-african yes well okay and are
you a full-time filmmaker at Chicago or
do you have another job I'm filming in
Chicago this is this is what I do this
type of provide for my family I don't do
anything else but make films but you
know again I have a have a marketing
company what I use to market you know my
films but the way I provide for my
families to family again okay so for
filmmakers who haven't figured out the
business side yet what advice can you
give them and how can you explain the
different ways that a filmmaker can get
out of having a nine-to-five job okay
great question here's how you can
definitely get out okay so say for
instance you ask the question that as
far as a filmmaker that makes a film for
$20,000 you go out you make a film for
$20,000 and what you have to do is okay
you have that $20,000 so you want to say
how can I make within two months how can
I make $40,000 you want to do a certain
amount of screenings so you can bring in
at least $40,000 now that $20,000 right
it's gonna go in if you use that your
own money too the only money
$20,000 to make your family or you use
investors money then you know all the
way off the top that that $20,000 gonna
go back to paying your investors back so
you can have your investors you pay your
investors back and you make it so you
have a profit of another $20,000 and
what you do with that $20,000 if you you
know if you have your own your home your
own place your apartment use some a
portion of that $20,000 to pay your rent
off with this for six months so you know
within six months that you you're
covered with your rent so you have a say
for instance after you pay you have
another ten thousand dollars left over
so you take another portion of that ten
thousand dollars right and what you do
is you have more screenings more screen
so you take it you may take enough to
another screen and you may invest maybe
three thousand dollars of that money
into another screening and don't look
into always screen it want to screen
your film and Ellen is very expensive
look out the southern places look at
Charlotte look at Atlanta look at that
is pretty expensive to go look at places
like South Carolina North Carolina
Nashville goggle different places like
that where they're looking for
filmmakers to come in to screen their
films and they will support because no
one else is doing this and so if you
take $3,000 of that money and you you go
out and you screen for like maybe three
days and you charge $10 a day and that
300 seats that's a total of $3,000 at
night that's now everything three nights
you're making $9,000 so that's a total
of $9,000 you made within three days you
know if you if depending on the number
of seats that you that you want to the
theaters that you want to write out so
you take that money and then what you do
is you take them when you make sure you
save so you already know that your rent
is paid up for six months right so
you're not now you have this film and
you're good for six months because
neither rent is paid up for six months
now that's
is no longer there because a lot of
things that keep us from from actually
being free it's the fear and is the
stress of not being able to pay our rent
if we know we have that six months now
we know that okay we have this film and
then this family this film now that we
have then we may be twenty thousand
dollars right now we want to look at how
we go how are we gonna do to get this
film so so now you want to start
pitching this film to you have your
destination Amazon you have different
companies who are always looking for
content like you know so you start to
pitch the film why are you pitching the
film you know you hit stay out of time
you can still be screening the two so as
you screening your film at these
different theaters you're constantly
making money so you have to be very
careful of the numbers you have to be
very careful of the numbers so a 20,000
dollar film you can make at least a
hundred thousand dollars if it's done
properly within an entire year and
that's profit if it's done properly but
you have to hit these do you have to hit
these these cities like the minute we
don't give out the Nashville's like the
challenge like this South Carolina's
these films that you know these cities
that nobody's water not New York not LA
probably not Seattle I wouldn't do New
York I won't do LA I would do Chicago
here's why here's why I would be Chicago
if I don't got a lot of theaters right
that's very affordable
you mean like safer as I can screen at
the ice theater which is a theater in
Chicago they may charge me $800 to
screen this fan but you're looking at a
theater assist 300 people charge to
allow those sell it out that's a profit
you know if you do that
two nights you do that for three nights
you just made what okay you made $9,000
so how I'm just curious how are you
getting people to go to these theaters
if you're not from that area like if I
were to go to Nashville and I wanted to
buy some time in a theater and then how
am I getting the word out great great
question so this is this is what I
normally would
is like what I would do it if I screen
and Charlotte if I take my film and I
screening this Charlotte which we have
done I would do I would partner with
someone who's over a film festival or a
song why who's who does marketing for
like clubs and things like that a
promoter so look up cuz you have all
these promoters like thank God for
social media so if you know somebody
that's someone that's a promoter in in
these particular cities cinema in box
and say okay I have a film that I want
you to promote and maybe we'll do a
70/30 deal I get seventy three thirty
now the promoter right is who maybe
promotes like four clubs or parties and
things like that they have something
different that they think can make money
off of so and they are very open because
if if it makes sense business-wise
they're open to it so they may take your
family say okay I'm going to promote it
for you in my city I can get the people
out let me do a 70 70/30 split you take
I take seventy that's the filmmaker you
take you take thirty okay you know you
gotta give them some for their time and
then we'll get the people out you know
they would get the people out to the to
the to the theater and you just do that
because their promoters are all over the
country you can find in one city can
find thousands and thousands of
promoters you know and just link up with
a promoter and or link up with a film
festival and I even like the smaller you
know like even like the smaller film
festivals in those different cities and
you have most cities you have film
festivals just link up with by the
director of the film fest or someone who
works for the film festival and say okay
I want to screen my film are you looking
to make some extra money and if you are
can we partner and you help me promote
it I come out and you know and we do a
70/30 split in most times most of who's
gonna turn it turn it like if I have an
audience already a built-in audience
that I'm promoting to it I know I can
get around your people out to a theater
or even 200 people out toward theater if
I want to see my screen a film they're
like that's just you know that's money
that's to be made it's a business deal
yeah have you tried the same thing here
in LA I know you said you you wouldn't
do it but I was just curious have you
have you tried other than with Film
Festival's we have screen like when I
did black coffee
we have screened at film in LA but it
was more it was more for marketing and
not for it to make to make money yeah
okay well outside of that you know like
Chicago Charlotte is in Charlotte this
is a great place to screen you know your
films that yeah if people are looking
you know they're looking for more
independent films so and they're looking
for more independent films to support
yeah so when when you did in LA did you
you realize like it'll probably be a
loss but we're doing it just to get the
word out ya know now here's the thing
too is that say for instance if you just
want to get the marketing or just say
okay I have my scream of him in LA to
use that as a as a a tool for the other
cities then you could do a screening and
I like knowing that you may break even
or you may make a profit like me mate or
you may not make a property may lose you
know you may be may gonna read but you
can just say I I scream I film in la la
la la has a lot of power again you know
you said you'll scream your stuff the
screen and I like that's going to put
the antennas up if you want enough okay
that's cool in LA so you know we can use
that as leverage in even New York
Chicago not not so much but LA New York
you can use that as leverage for the
smaller smaller cities yes how did you
figure the business model out on how to
make money with these small phones oh I
always knew that I had to keep the films
at a very low so if you for me $20,000
was a too much to spend on the film in
particularly especially if you don't
have name actors in it
so I knew that I'm going to keep the
films about $10,000 and from $10,000 I
can make that back and within a weekend
right and so I knew
I had want to keep these fans low I'm
gonna make that profit back you know I'm
gonna reinvest until doing more
screenings you know I'm gonna first and
foremost you know like by keeping it so
low you know you can you can pay if you
have investors you can pay your
investors back whether it's a thousand
dollars five hundred dollars whatever
but you can also you can there's this
this because a 90-minute film is like
it's a 90-minute film right so people
don't people are not we know that they
don't know what you pay to get the film
eight they don't they're not aware of
that you don't have to tell people oh I
made this film for $20,000 no one that
needs to know that but if if a film like
let's say for instance black panther
right comes out of course you know means
a million dollars for marketing you know
so you have people who go on a rush but
it's still like if a feature film
$20,000 feature films a feature film so
what you're gonna do is you're gonna
definitely use that $20,000 if you want
to shoot that film for $20,000 you have
to adjust you have to look at it as if
as if it's a studio even though it's not
a studio film but you have to treat it
like this is my studio film because
again you are a studio we are you know
you know we may not be having the
millions and hundreds of million dollars
to do marketing or to to do a film I
mean to uh to put in a film but your
$20,000 film you have to you have to use
the same method the same process that
the studios are doing for this family so
you take it out you screen it you make
money off of it you continue to you know
continue to screen it you could you know
until it because people want again
people want to see those independent
films like Hollywood people the
blockbuster stuff so this is a perfect
time for independent filmmakers because
there are so many everything that's
coming out of Hollywood is blockbuster
and not every one every one we want to
see a good love story we want to see a
good dramatic film a good story without
things have it to be blown up so this is
like the perfect time for us you know
and then you take it to again
it's an old small cities you take it to
those and just it's just screen your
film and that's how you make money you
can make money you can make a living off
just screening your family have all of
your films made money all of them every
last one of them yeah area every last
film I've ever made all made a profit
because we make them so like if I'm
making a film for a thousand dollars or
ten thousand dollars if I can't make a
profit off that I don't need to make it
I don't need to be making films like if
you make it if I make like the movie I
made black butterfly which we made for
less than $10,000 like we sold it we
made money off of it and they put it out
you know again and they put it out you
know I could say there's no but I was
still selling DVDs I was thinking like
you know like if you keep them if you
keep you know I had a screen I was still
doing screenings at a film that's how I
was that's how I was able to make make a
living you know is is by screening these
films is by making DVDs are you going
online it is just don't depend on like
the YouTube the youtube when and what
would you call it the Apple and all you
have to go out and you have to screen
your family you know you have you have
to mean you we have to make money off of
our fans yeah so you know though there's
this new term hustle life you know it's
been around for a little bit and we
think of all these influencers and stuff
but it sounds like you I've been doing
this for years in terms of just going
out there selling stuff yourself we saw
it a lot in the music world especially
back with with CDs do you think
filmmakers today have enough of that
hustle life in them or they view it
differently like I'm just gonna give
this to a distributor I made my film
I spent whatever time with it three
years with it now I'm giving it to a
distributor they can take care of it and
is that a mistake to think like that no
it's not a mistake here's why I think I
think it depends on how much the
distributor gives you for your family
and we also have to keep in mind
most distributors are not going to be
honest with us so say for an offender
for $100,000 in the distributor and you
give your you'll film away from free
like you have to be very careful and
make sure that an attorney looks over
all of your paperwork just don't give
your family you just can't give your
film away for free thinking that
distributor is gonna be honest with you
and gonna be cutting you a check so you
always have to leave room you always
have to leave room like if say for
instance if you make your film $400,000
if you decide okay I want to give just
to get your film out there I want to
give the the distributor the film just
to put out because I wanted to sit in
Walmart I want to sit on Netflix
well if you're not getting any money for
it you know you have to leave whereas
you can do theatrical or you can do DVD
and you could do streaming meaning that
you know you have to leave room so you
can it's a partnership if you want to
take my family okay you can take my fail
but I the hell I have to have the
ability to - we can do this together
meaning that I'm going to I'm going to
distribute the film as well you know you
can take it to whoever you want to take
it to but you know this is a partnership
you have to we have to we just can't
give our fans away to people so you know
but if we do give it away you know
meaning no money upfront
then you have to have the ability to
make DVDs streaming on your own you know
in fight for they've made a distributor
and the distributor is honest with you
you know they'll give you some money up
front for you'll fail you know but going
back to the term hustle life or whatever
it is just just work ethic do you think
that artists have enough of that in them
no here's the reason why I think with
the whole thing with the streaming
services now that people will rather sit
behind the computer and just put it on
on Amazon Prime because this is all you
can put on Amazon
and you can market it on the your social
media and you'll have to do a lot of
hustle or you don't have to do a lot of
legwork I think that's a big mistake now
if you do put it on Amazon Prime what
you have to do is you have to still go
out still go out you have to go out to
events you have to have you some like
what we call in Chicago flyers and
pluggers and give it to people and make
sure people are actually going on Amazon
Prime because they're not gonna know
what is on it even if if you have a
5,000 followers one on on Facebook it's
only gonna reach about 20 people
that's think that's the way they have it
set up so so you know but you can also
spend a couple of dollars with Facebook
to to promote it you know but go out and
talk to the people go out to these
different events every time an event is
going on or even a party is going on go
out and just give out plugins or flyers
you have to market so we just did what
for black and privileged behind the wire
we did a billboard if we have a
billboard in the angular community which
is right off the expressway so you have
thousands of people who are driving
through in essence big billboard you
know so we have to but you have to leave
room for marketing dollars and that's
the thing we don't do is that we don't
leave that room for marketing dollars so
if you raise $20,000 who should have
found make sure you're trying to
liberate another 5,000 to market the
film because worst thing is you want
people of people not watching your
family you know marketing is very very
very important when it comes to our
family we should know that like marking
it so I don't think that filmmakers have
that hustle that they did back no you
know no one like the nineties in the
early 2000 because of the streaming
services we want to sit behind a
computer upload it and then let it do
what it do but no you have to still do
that legwork you know just like if you
drive down the different Hollywood
Boulevard you drive down LA downtown LA
and you still want to see billboards you
still want to see the posters up because
there somebody is out there actually
putting those posters up you know and it
doesn't take a lot of money to do that
well if you own that and that aspect
yeah but we can still do that because
a lot of money to put up a billboard so
so there's a company that you work with
or that you've worked with before to do
the Billboard and then what were you
advertising black and privileged for
like the screening or the just a movie
just oh just the movie the movie so when
people when people drive past is just a
billboard
did you see you know what we remote the
movie beginning I think in his call for
getting Sarah Sarah Marshall yeah
remember when I think it was like 10
years ago when that movie came out and
it was just like you saw the posters all
over the play was like what then right I
think I remember that yeah like what is
this you know saying like people want to
know what it is just forgetting sarah
marshall like that it was just like just
the words and people what's going on
who's what you know that's what I was
thinking like what's going on when is
this happen and so that's the same thing
I want but when I was put the Billboard
up when people drive past and they see
biking privilege I wanna know what is
this
like when is it coming out I want them
to ask questions because when they start
asking questions then not you're in a
conversation with them you know and then
and that's what you want you want that
conversation so it wasn't even a direct
call to action for them to go to a
certain site or what it was just to
pique their curiosity absolutely job
site in the subliminal you know if job
no job pay as they say oh okay
and they always going to remember it so
say for instance if something comes up
on the social media or they go and they
google it and say cuz I'm sure a lot of
people are Google and say okay what can
I find is that you know because it okay
and the title is a very catchy title and
then 100 what can I find this you know
so that's what we our objective is to
get people online into Google the the
blackett prevalence movie yeah forgive
me mark I've only known you for a few
hours here but I'm gonna ask you kind of
a personal question and I hope you won't
get too mad at me know what's the most
broke you've been as a filmmaker the
most broken no no that's not personally
the most broken being it was when you
when you have to look underneath your
car to find change for coffee or gas
money we have to say you know you have
to don't you know
yeah I've been pretty broke as a
filmmaker you know been you know you
know especially me as it as a
screenwriter
you know and not not having my and night
before as far as directing but you know
as a screenwriter you know you want to
you know that you see you have that
mentality where somebody's gonna pick up
my work or somebody's gonna do my fail
and you just like you just yeah so I
mean there are times when you you know
you you know you have to scrape on in
your car and say okay you know first we
change or whatever but you know that's
just you know that's this part of your
you you evolving you evolving and you're
growing as a filmmaker and as a and as a
entrepreneur and as an artist is you
evolving so do those times stay with you
or oh they don't you mean in terms of in
your mind not not like you carry out
that reality but I mean does it stay
with you in your mind or you always
remember that no I do not mean is it's
not that I always remember it is the
fact that I'm thankful for those times
you know I'm thankful you know
especially when you know when I hit the
page of business and the cleaners and I
decided okay this is the film business
what I'm gonna do for time and close
those down and plus the page the
business was getting old no one was bad
pages anymore and those those earlier
times it was like you know and now and I
write and I you know those early times
were tough you know and but you it's
something just trying to figure out you
had to figure out okay I'm gonna you
know I'm gonna sell my DVDs you know
because initially will tell you
initially right I had no initially when
I did my first film I was like you know
I wasn't thinking whether I wasn't I
wasn't thinking if I wanted sent it to
distributor or
I wanted to go door-to-door so it was
something to ask like okay I did this
with the with the page of business then
I know I can do it with the film
business you know but I was just wanting
to make a movie that was the main my
main objective is to make a movie it
wasn't just to but I knew that at the
end of the day in order to make this
movie that I know I know okay
this movie has to make me money order
for me to survive so you know you just
gotta you know those those times were
tough but you know I just had to adjust
adjust and go out there and you know you
know go out there and hustle and sell
those DVDs did you ever have anything
shut off no that's good no for a few
years my early twenties so I know what
that's like so I wasn't sure it was
actually kind of freeing not having DVDs
I could wanna make money so you know I
can go out and say you know long sigh I
knew this is like the DVDs for me was
money you know I'm gonna take and I'm
like you know I'm gonna take 20 DVDs I'm
just gonna go out I'm gonna sell those
DVDs but I had to sell for $10 or $5 I'm
gonna make I'm going to sell those DVDs
so that was money for me so most
independent filmmakers I would say would
probably lose money on their projects
what do you think is the reason is it
the mindset they're not doing the proper
research on what the budget should be
the budget oh yeah you have to you have
to you have to make sure like when you
when you if you're doing a film for
million dollars you can't use your
friends you have to make sure you use
actors that's gonna get you that money
making out let's back if you do a so
when I was doing when I was doing
feeling for twenty thousand dollars or
ten thousand dollars or thousand dollars
I used I used local actors who didn't
have a name but when that decided my
first film that I actually got which is
a film called black coffee why I
actually got money from our LJ which is
Bob Johnson's company we didn't shoot
that Final Four
money but I knew that they knew that I
just can use those same actors because
it would be a hard sell for BT or to TV
while or whoever so we needed to use
name actors so if you're gonna do a film
for $500,000 over even a hundred
thousand dollars you have to make sure
that you the most important thing is for
me was or the most important thing for
filmmakers make sure that we are able to
pay back our investors that's very
important
now if the investors know in any field
that you can pay them back then we
invest and then what you can do is you
can form a form a partnership where they
can continue to reinvest in your fans so
again you make if you're making a film
for fifteen thousand four hundred
thousand dollars make sure that you use
at least two two names at least two
names that's gonna least gonna get you
in that money back to you so you can pay
back your investors and also you can
make some money yeah can you explain how
named actors get you money back so the
way the way it works is this so if I'm
like I'm going to use let me use black
coffee as an example so I'm going to
tell you the budget and everything so
that movie was made for a hundred and
twenty thousand dollars so in that movie
we did like so we had Darin Hanson hey
Gabriel Dennis we had Erica Hubbard
Lamarr working at Christian Keyser's on
May 5 and these are named actors people
know them that you know you may not know
their name but you see their faces know
them and they were BT friendly like BT
like you show those people to BT they'd
norm so when you when you a movie like
that was made for $120,000 you started
BT make it 250 back you know you make it
a little bit more back you know that's
how that's the way you're making your
money is you know is television you know
it's television now so that's how you
you know you get a movie and you have to
do your research to now if you're doing
a horror film no no the actors that are
good with when it comes to horror films
and know who's picking up horror films
what is
what networks are picking up the horror
films and what this romantic comedy know
which networks on which distribution
companies are picking up romantic
comedies know which actors that they
like go on their way up to the different
websites with the different distributors
and see the movies that they are putting
out and see the movies that are high so
stay friends and go to the different
different television shows and see what
television shows are hot and a lot of
actors who are doing TV they want to do
feature films you know they of course
they don't so if you go onto if you see
like you go to like one of my favorite
shows like this is us
if you have a great script you know that
you know what you want to do is you want
to contact the agents you know tell them
what the script is about you want to
make an offer to like you know I said
for instance one of the actors from this
is I'll say I want you is the lead role
so you know that that television show is
hot now everyone loves this is us by
using one of those actors from this is
us you know and you keep the budget very
low between 150-200 depends you know you
may want to do a partnership without
with those actors it say okay I want you
to come in I want you to be the lead and
I want you to be the producer as well
and as a producer I'm going to give you
some money up front and then you want to
make money on the back end once we sell
it so you use that those actors name in
order to say your project so who's want
to turn down like the sterling Brown
from this is us who want to turn out a
movie with sterling Brown in it because
he's so hot right now you know so you go
and you just do your research and as far
as what television shows are hot and
what television shows are high and then
what you do is you reach out to those
different actors who maybe not doing a
lot of top feature films and you know
and when they have a break from shooting
like a show like this is also when I was
show that show me when they have a break
from shooting from underneath no shows
they may have the time to shoot your
feature fail but do a partnership with
them like Gabriel Dennis and I you know
she just played Whitney Houston on the
barbering story like we did the movie my
first love
it was it was a party she came on as an
executive producer you
and it was a lack of partnership so you
want to do a partnership with these
different actors as well how did you
learn that type of partnership where you
felt like you could ask a named actor or
recognizable face to be an investor as
well
well because actors are looking they
want to produce more most actors if you
talk to him and if there's the project
and the script is really good and if
they have the time and if it makes sense
for them they would definitely take the
time to read it and if they like it they
would join on and they were joined on
and they would come on as a producer and
as an actor you know or you maybe may
want to attach them to the project and
you know test them to the project that
making get you while to investors think
the money from an investor say okay I
have such and such acting attached to
this project you know maybe you can go
to a company like HBO or Showtime
whatever and get maybe like I'm just
tossing some companies names out on
Netflix or Amazon Prime and get an mg
which is a minimum guarantee and say
okay I have this actor attached to it to
this project you go to these companies
say can you give me a minimum guarantee
that said that and we finish this
project with this actor attached that
this is the amount of money that you're
going to give me for this film so what
these what the a network or television a
network or a streaming network like a
Netflix may do there are no promises or
guarantees and what they may do is they
will give you a ladder mg which is the
minimum guarantee that it's saying that
based off the production value based off
these actors or this actor if you
deliver this film to us we'll give you a
certain amount of money and what you do
is you take that letter and you take
that letter to investor just say okay
and you take that minimum guarantee
letter you take the attachment letter
from that actor and you can take that to
like investors and say okay I can make
this movie with this actor and Netflix
or Amazon or Hulu said that once the
film is finished the production value is
there and this actors onboard and stars
in his film that they would give me such
as such and such and such and
that's how that's how we get my family
coffee made because what happened was I
called up our LJ I was like I want to do
this film it was like who do you have
attached
I had relationship with Gabriel Dennis I
hate relationship with Lamar Walker and
it's funny because I met Leroy mallomar
Rucker at a film festival in New York a
long time ago I was like we got to work
together so we exchanged numbers it was
years later that I reached out to him I
got an attachment letter from Gabriel a
dentist Darin Hanson the market
Christian keys in Ericka Hubbard and
Eric Roberson what I've been known for a
long time so once I got that attachment
letter from them
I took it to those not attachment letter
I sent it to our LJ entertainment within
24 hours less than 24 hours they say
okay we want to make this project
because they had actors not attached to
it so if you get that attachment letters
from the actors plus the distribution
company you go to investors and say okay
you know this is how much money so say
for instance if they say they're gonna
give you $500,000 back based off this
out there you go to it you go to an
investor you say okay I'm going to make
this movie for 350 I need 350,000 to
make this movie so you make the movie
for 350,000 you take it to the network
that's going to give you $500,000 for
the film now you just made 150 thousand
dollar profit so now you can pay back
your investors and you can pay back you
can pay them back with a with the return
on their investment yeah and and that
was your fourth film that you made that
was that was filming about I think four
or five my coffee black off yeah okay so
black coffee was about a story about a
guy who he gets fired from his job and
he falls for this young lady who's an
attorney and who encourages him to go in
business for himself you know and so now
I mean it played on Beatty for like four
years and they played on now he's on
balance and so again I own the rights to
like also make sure that you you own the
rights to your content that's very
important they stop owning the rights to
your content you can always get paid off
your cuts
if you don't want to rise to your
content someone else's get paid pay it
off your content so don't sell your
films to distributors never sell it you
what you do is you license it we would
like to do a three-year deal you know
sometime they're gonna ask for a 25 year
deal sometimes wise for seven year deal
do it three years three years and don't
ever sell your content don't sell the
content so what's the science behind
three years because then if they want to
renew it you can do it you can
renegotiate at a higher rate
yeah well the signs be 23 years is they
have you got three years you know
so everything that three years so many
people have watched it and probably with
loses value unless by somebody from that
film win an Oscar you know so within
three years that you know they can
always you know you can you you can take
that fear within three years and then
you can resell it and continue to make
money off of it so you're talking about
seven years they go that's like they'll
Pippen your film within seven years it
you probably never see another dime but
that upfront money so you may so within
three years you can get that feedback
within three years and you can resell it
again own every sell it but relicense it
yeah so you don't ever sell you your car
take control your your masters control
your content just license your projects
out
have you ever realized one of your films
yes we just recently realized this black
coffee to balance so it was on bt
initially i hate we license for three
years on bt then we bring up for another
year we bt and then after that license
would be t we did another we did a
renewal not every no but we license it
to the balance TV so yeah we've realizes
a lot of projects quite often again
that's how you that's how the filmmakers
make real money is by controlling your
content not giving you a content way to
distributors for over three years and
that's there for every time you use
licence your project you make money off
of it every every three you know you
make money off of it and especially in
the front end of the deal oh yes oh yeah
so what they most companies what they do
is they either give you something on the
frontier or they pay in increments so
they may pray they say for is if they
license for a year they may give you
they definitely give you something
upfront and then they may do something
like every three months it says all paid
off yeah
did the companies ever try to bully you
into certain terms and try to steer you
and say well it's you know it'll be
better if we just wait till the end of
this this contract term and it will give
you big lump sum then or yeah don't ever
believe that unfortunately a lot of
distributors are not honest so they give
you promises that they definitely can't
keep so if so that's why I'm saying like
they their job is to control your
content because they know it's to own
your content or to license your content
for for as many years as possible
because this is how to keep their
company alive and afloat but you know
selling your the rai co pham to to the
different television networks and things
like that and also what they do they
call it they call it a twenty five
percent distribution fee don't ever do
that
distributors don't like it I mean
distributors they come okay so this is
what happens right they said we will do
a 50/50 split so but
we're going to do a 25% license fee so
if you do a 50-50 split with the
distributor but before anybody sees any
money they have to take 25 that means
that they take 25% off whatever is made
of top so what essentially what is
happening is that instead of doing a
50/50 split they get 75% and they're
giving you 25% that's why you see that
25% distribution fee don't do it at all
because you're not making any not making
any real money and then another thing
you have to be very careful of is the
marketing fee cap off your marketing fee
so some some company some companies said
okay we're gonna spare 80,000 or 100,000
of marketing mmm that's not that's not
going to happen I'm talking about I'm
not talking about like your big major
studios
I'm talk about you know the we talked
about films that I made fun you know but
independent films then go to my smaller
distribution companies so for a
distribution company telling you that
they're spending $100,000 marketing do
not believe they put $75,000 down but
what they do is they do no marketing at
all so they can just do a couple of
posts on social media and they can write
that stuff off so distribution feed and
distribution fee for 25% do not do that
deal do not do the distribution fee and
do not if you want to do a marketing fee
you wanna you want to make sure that you
know where they give you a list of where
they're gonna market your film at and
not only a list but how much they're
going to charge my say for instance if
they go on to that they gonna do some
marketing for and inside of the New York
Post or inside of a magazine
but you want to know how actually how
much they pay for that marketing you
want to know you just wanna you wanna
things out of my eyes you know or you
can cap it off and say okay just
marketing for $5,000
you know but they I wouldn't I wouldn't
do a deal with a company and they gonna
take 25% just distribution fee or
they're gonna take
35000 or they have marketing up and
because you would in the reason they do
that is because before you see a dime
they have to recoup that mark anything
that's how they able to that's how
they're able to not pay filmmakers is
because of the marketing which they
never do did you find that out the hard
way I found it out the hard way oh yes
this distribution fee and because I
didn't know again like when I did was
doing I did my earlier films is like you
know the I had to find out the hard way
I was like what the hell is the
distribution fee what I mean is that you
know we charge you 25 percent just to
distribute your film
I'm like no so you do find out the hard
way marketing you're thinking that you
actually think that they're gonna put
marketing into your film but they're not
you know they're gonna do a couple of
social media post and they can always
you know and that's how they get you and
then you would never see you would never
see money from your family at all at all
and it's unfortunate are you able to
talk about one of the biggest financial
risks you've taken with one of your
films the biggest anything so we just
did black and privilege which is again I
want I want to investors to get money we
do spend a lot of money on on the film
but again that's money and we still have
to go back and pay the investors so it's
a risk so I already I'm going to with
this particular project I'm looking to
license it out so you know to get their
investors back their money but I already
say for instance if no one wants to put
it out I already have a plan how I'm
going to pay them my investors back you
know I always I always have a back-up
plan that plan just in case distributors
say you know we don't want to put it out
and one of the things is I always try to
keep the projects the budgets low
whereas okay I know that by doing this
this a B
see that I can at least paint my
investors back their money you know if
peeling back their money so I don't I
don't go into I don't go into it into
making a film with a big risk because of
the budgets that we deal with you know
so if I do a film for five million
dollars you best believe it's gonna be
on it's gonna be a theatrical release
whereas it's gonna be on a studio level
because I'm not going to go out and get
that type of money from an investor
without any possibility of know how I'm
gonna pay that investors back their
money that's very important to me is we
have to break it with integrity
integrity and make sure that you know
we're able to pay because you know like
people back their money and so that's
that's important I don't take those type
of risk what other people's money yeah
do you pitch distributors an idea for
your screenplay before you begin making
them no no that never so what I do what
I do is if I have an idea for a movie I
let it play out over and over again and
I actually I write the screenplay out I
have me a good solid first draft before
I even talk to any distribution
companies or producers and what I do is
once I have a solid first job which
people can read but I know that it's
gonna have to I'm gonna have to make
changes to it is when I decide this is
when I'm gonna pitch to the to to a
distribution company or producer but I'd
never ever pitched just an idea yeah
just to see like does this sound viable
do you would you want to take this title
on you've never know okay I've never
there are people filmmakers who have
done that before but I wouldn't feel
comfortable pitching just an idea to a
producer or unless it's like a comedy
show whereas something that's unscripted
yeah I've done that before but an actual
scripted narrative feature film
no III really no I wouldn't feel
comfortable just pitching it out there
like that
you know I have to have something like
when they say yes I have something I can
just cinema directly over to them you
know and so they can go ahead and read
it so we can move forward yeah
what are five things a distributor once
in a movie cast production value cast
production value in most importantly
what goes into the production value is
great sound it really honestly is this
is really they looking for a cast and
production value cast you know longest
you have a nice cast and you have good
sound they don't read too much care
about the story to be honest with you
they care more about who's in it that's
what they do really like who's in it
that's the flag when I'm talking to
distributors and you know that's the
first thing
who's in it and if they don't care they
rarely asked about they want you know
after after you talk about who's in it
what's the production what's the budget
then they may say okay what is it about
but outside of that I mean I don't think
they're even five things that they look
for I think they like okay you know long
as they can do a nice art artwork for
the foot of film and put it out there
they're cool with that
they don't too much care about the story
unless it's like you know they don't
they don't know you know they want to
make sure that the production of value
is there and they want to make sure that
the sound is great and I want to make
sure that they have a cast that they can
they can sell but one of the most
important thing is a recognizable faces
the cast more than one or would one do
it uh it depends on the one but I will
say to be on the safe side definitely to
to but with some solid actors around but
to to name actors she should
yeah but like I said for instance if you
if you do a film with
asaji bow like you know I don't think
that she was gonna she's gonna do a film
with there's nobody another somebody
that's not recognizable you know it's
not she's not good it's gonna be just to
only start in the film because that's
her value and she has so much value now
say for instance if she does say for
instance she fries the scrip and the
actors that's that I write how so strong
and she said I want to do this I want to
be the only face of course you know that
you could sell off a larger boat like
with her you know that's you know that
goes without saying
so it just all depends on that one
particular actor yeah what did writing
your first screenplay teach you about
screenwriting oh my god
so when I wrote my first screenplay I
did now this is the difference between
writing a screenplay and when I was
directing before where my first
screenplay of course see if is is like
you know you I don't think as a
screenwriter I don't think that you can
really be assigned a screenwriter if you
have a study state feels you know in
vibrate a lot of screenplays
tons of screen planes before I even
started writing screenplays I read see
it feels booking I've continued to read
his books you know but tons of
screenplays so when I first bought my
first screenplay you know and that's not
that you know it never got produced of
course and I took it out people Randy
he's like that's pretty decent but it
wasn't good it wasn't good so it was
only I wrote it was only after after
writing at least 10 screenplays before I
actually decided you know if I actually
produce my own stuff so but it taught me
a lot they told me a lot he's like that
I didn't play with at all because I knew
that the order to sit down and write
there has to be a particular structure
and that's what when one of these two is
that one of the things is very important
as screenwriters in this film make is
that when you when you're pitching to
people to the producers you have to make
sure that the screenplay is properly
structured just use use a final draft
and you have to have vest
like enough to really we have to really
really invest in ourselves in our craft
go out and get the final Jeff program go
out in reset fields book know how to
read tons and tons of screenplays you
know and make sure that when you
actually pitch to producers that's
properly formatted there's nothing worse
then someone says they have an idea they
have an idea and they pitch you an idea
but they want you to write that idea
like I have tells the screenplay
tomorrow or filmmakers or
screenwriters want you to read their
screenplays and it's not properly
formatted I hate that I'm like there's
no way I kind of like recently someone
gave me asked me to read their
screenplay
they had the heading and everything was
written like I'm not gonna play I was
like there's a difference between a
screenplay in a stage play and in I
don't think people understand that when
you're writing a screenplay it's
formatted and it's formatted a
particular way because we're dealing
with different setups those are very
important and I had to explain to the
person who it was just read it I was
like it's hard to for me as a filmmaker
that's hard to follow when you don't
have like the proper headings on it you
know like the interior I don't know
where I'm at in this for me just thought
it is I can't follow it and put those
are very important weather because like
now we have this this is one set up so
if we go outside then that's a different
set up so you have to make sure that you
that is that is in a screen playing like
it's an exterior so I've read
screenplays when you can have that I'm
like there's no way I can read this
because if people don't understand you
they think you're hating because you is
they're making it difficult to read
their screen presence because they don't
want to follow the proper structure you
Paulo you follow the proper structure
then it would make it as much easier for
us to read your screenplay yeah how was
it for you to get your first feedback
because you know you talked about
feedback earlier in the interview and
how it's important and was it the first
time you showed someone your screenplay
what was that feel oh god it was
it was the feedback I got was okay you
know it was it's something that you have
to grow and to evolve but again like me
a smart a this is this this is not
properly this is not you know you you
like or the story is not connecting you
like why why you get it you can get off
edit bad but the thing is is that you
can't be because if we want to grow
evolve we have to listen to constructive
criticism you know if someone is like
telling you giving you some constructive
criticism I know it's hard for us to
deal with it and what's hard for me is
like still today you know when the
people get I have to be more open-minded
you know when we when we need my
screenplays and people give me you know
I you know it's it's difficult you have
to train your mind like I have to always
train my mind that that keep telling
myself that I think this is necessary
this is necessary this feedback is
necessary because sometimes we don't
want to you know I was just watching the
movie the wife oh yes excellent yes
excellent movie excellent and when his
wife gave him that feedback he just blew
up right because he didn't want to hear
that you know he didn't want to hear
that feedback you know so but but at the
end of the day well I think if he had a
listen to it he probably would have
become a better writer and instead of
her you know I'm gonna tell a story it's
better you know her what happened but
you know we have to listen to those
voices that give us those voices that
give us that constructive criticism so
we can evolve I know it's difficult so
even today I always have to when I'm
letting someone read my screenplay and
they giving me feedback on them I have
to keep telling myself over and over
again this is necessary
I need this you know is in when it when
it when that feedback is difficult to
hear just repeat I need this I need this
because it's very important it's it's to
to allow us to grow in for us to evolve
and just put the ego aside you know we
have to put that ego aside at all times
even while I'm say put the ego outside
and listen to the people who can make
our projects better
you said structure is very important to
you so do you outline your screenplay I
do so I do outline what I do is like
again before I even write anything or do
any outlines
I have the I always have I know how the
storms gonna end maybe start and I know
how it's gonna get if I don't know the
ending of a screenplay I don't touch it
at all
I mean the story I don't even start
writing so once I know how the project
is going to start and how it's gonna end
and then that started to my outline and
once I started my outline and is after I
finished my outline is when I actually
start to actually put the screenplay
together so I don't like the first draft
we already know writing is rewriting is
rewriting so I know most like that first
draft done
that's just my first rap is really also
my outline you know and then I start to
tweak and change things and change
dialogue and so I'm gonna do a couple of
drafts so that mean I'm Way more than a
couple of drafts so maybe like you know
then I once I get it to where I said
okay I can stand to read this I send out
to different people to read it to give
me feedback
once they give me a feedback I go
through and I clean it up again and once
I get like a nice a nice polished script
like I sent to producers and that's what
I was doing then I was sending to
producers but knowing that this is still
a project that a script that more likely
I'm gonna have to do some rewriting to
even up until when we don't say you know
there are certain times when or do a
temporary so I think wasn't what wasn't
very important it was even before we go
on we start to shoot is to do a table
read so you can listen to the dialogue
you know and you don't necessarily do a
table read with the actors that you're
gonna that you want to use or the actors
you want to hire you know you can bring
use local are local actors bring them in
and even before you get the budget even
before you even send it out to producers
you know bring some local actors in and
let them you know do table reads so you
can listen to the dollar and buy listen
to the dialogue
then once once the once you are you
finished with the dialogue you know ask
the actors what do you all think give me
some feedback you know and then we'll
give you some brilliant so the actors
they would give you some good feedback
and why not giving you feedback just
always be taking notes and there you
know there's some stuff you you're
barely use and stuff and some stuff
you're not gonna be in videos this is
something that I do is that now what I
do is be even before I send anything out
to producers I'm going to do a table
read with local actors which they're
gonna know look this is I'm not hiring
anybody this is what I need for you
ought to do for me so I can listen to
the dialogue and then they're happy to
do that for you know yeah yeah yeah I
know a lot of comments underneath some
of your trailers say the great dialogue
that you have so do you do you read any
of those comments like do you go to some
of your trailers and look at the I do
yeah the comments you know I think I
think as me for me I do I go to Amazon
ago to YouTube I just read what people
are saying and the good but I start what
I do is I go and I click on say for
instance if it's on Amazon you have that
one two three four I go to the worst and
I read all of that I want only you want
to call it the negative comments you
know but the comments that I'd not like
the I guess is the ones and which is the
the so-called negative comments right so
I read those now go to the - I'll go to
the three I'll go to the floor then I go
to the more quote positive comments you
know that's in favor of the family but I
always want to know what people are
thinking what people are saying and how
because with that people are because
these are people you don't know your mom
your sister your friends and family and
your friends when they hate them they
hate to hurt us
you know you know so when they looking
at our president well this is great this
is great you know but the people are
actually
I'm not associated with us at all
they're gonna give it to you in wrong so
I go and I now you know and it's some of
the stuff is like it's hurt but it's
needed
it's neatest definitely mean I think
that we all should go and read those
comments because you know to see what we
can all we can work on yeah so I read
those comments yeah when you do the
table read do is this more like a a
working atmosphere or do you make it
more like a fun atmosphere where there's
food and you're sitting around a table
and people feel comfortable or is it
more this is business so it's full oh
yeah yeah so temporary
I always felt like I had water have
juice I have you know or some peace or
whatever some chips and we sitting
around you know because in Chicago what
I normally do my table reserved like the
people that I bring in these are friends
too like these are people who I've been
knowing for 10 15 years in the business
well just you know just want to you know
we all want to just you know help each
other out so we come in we just sit back
and they read the dialogue and they're
very I thought I need you all to be
brutal I need you all to be honest with
me and there are they tell me like they
let me know how you know what the you
know where we missing things i or you
know so that's how we that's our you
know that's how we able to evolve but we
make we make enough fun and I think if
we make by making in a fun environment
that it opens the actors up to be a
little bit more honest so if this is all
about people being rigid or business
people a little bit could be a little
bit more dishonest because they may be
afraid that you know they don't want to
hurt our feelings or that this may be an
opportunity for them to be acting it and
if they give negative feedback that you
may not hire them you may take it
personal you know so no you can't take
anything personal
so for me I'm not like I like it to be a
fun environment so people can be mopping
it could be more honest and give me
feedback like I suppose I'm reading a
line that says like Joe you didn't call
me last night and it just doesn't sound
right is the actor gonna say can I just
stop here for a second can I say
what's up with not calling me or so
where were you instead I mean like it
how are they giving you feedback are
they doing it while they're reading or
no afterwards
Oh afterward okay so the rule is to just
read through one time and what we do is
we read through one time and while we're
reading through they're taking notes and
why they taking notes what we do is
after they finish arena screenplay then
we go through and we you know and we are
and they give notes now there may be a
situation where like we're reading
through it somebody may stop and say
that you know that stop and say that but
I don't I don't I don't I don't stop
them I like you know and we made but I
don't because I want to stay all night
stay focused on finishing the screenplay
I let them say but we don't stay on it
for very long so it's okay we will get
back to that so we make a notation we
come back tonight but we definitely want
to stay focused and get get over to get
done with the screenplay and once we get
down to screenplay and then you know
everybody's just like going in digging
air
so do you when you do the notes session
with the actors do you do it in in order
of the script like you start with the
first page and yes oh yeah yeah so we
first what I do is first I say okay
allow them to like I say like go around
the table we go around the table and
give me your feedback you know and and
maybe it's like I don't want too much
like the positive feedback I don't pay
too much attention to the positive
feedback is there I have it there but I
want to hear the negative feedback or
the feedback that I'm gonna use in order
to make the story better the positive
stuff the stuff that's good in a
screenplay is they're cool but the stuff
that that's that we need to change or
tweak those are type of things that I
like to hear or want to hear so once we
go through the around the table
everybody give their take on what they
thought about the screenplay how we can
make it better there we go okay we go
didn't go through the school - the
script is saying that's not asking
questions so what do you think about
this and what you think about that do
you like this or
so I start to ask questions so I can get
deep deep into the screenplay and you
know and then once she started to ask
some questions to the actors it's like I
need you I really need y'all to tell me
give me your honest opinion about this
you know and they open up and they give
it to you and they say you know I don't
feel like my character would do that yes
oh oh yeah you get a lot I don't think
you like oh yeah you hear you know I
don't think I don't think my character
would do that and I want like oh why
don't you think that this character
we're doing it you know here's why I
think oh okay that makes this you know
then you go in you make the adjustment
what are your secrets to writing great
dialogue so this is what I do this is
well I haven't done it in a long time
maybe in quite a few years but what I
would do is I would well in this aspect
so early on in my film career I would
write the the CT engine which is the bus
the train and I was just listening to
people talk and based on listen to
people talk I just get a feel of like I
just sit there and just listen to people
talk and now it's always listening to
people talk and like if I'm at the
grocery store as always I'm
eavesdropping so I can know how you know
like people like I think I'm picking up
on certain things
the flow the flow of dialogue and I'm
just just listening so I think that
that's very very important is just to
listen and then also I think with when
it comes to great dialog like Kevin
Smith is great when it comes to dialog
and I think his film should be stunning
because his dialogue is so it's amazing
so let definitely look at films with
great dialogue and you know and but one
of the most important things for me is
to actually go to different places and
always listen to where people talk
we have to listen and whether it's the
church you want this work regardless of
where you at the grocery store just
listen to conversations yeah I don't
know if you have time to go down to
Venice Beach but if you walk up and down
that Strand area
Wow he will hear just like these
snippets of the most fascinating
conversation for people who yes really I
mean some of it can't even I can't even
repeat it so you know coffee shops oh
great so that's true yeah yeah yeah so
I'll go out like in Chicago go to a
coffee I'll go to I just sit there like
and I'm listen to people like this and
like this is some interesting and I pick
up words like words like you know
especially from young people and I hear
like stuffing in and then another thing
too is that like my son's like my son's
they're young
but you know if they say things I'm like
what the hell what does this mean so I
had to call my son's up and ask them
what does this make I see stuff on
Facebook that people post and stuff I
have not liked and I called my sons I'm
like what does this actually mean and
you have to ask to tell me the meaning
to it and you know if I want to use it
then you know you know those type of
things I do as well
yeah have you ever written a screenplay
where the intention was not to film it
yourself was it to just write it for a
director for hire to make another
company to take off yeah my first 10
screenplays were like that was was
actually it was written for other
directors to direct because I had no
desire at all to direct films at all it
wasn't until I did why men cheat in any
way everything after that is for me it
was like I'm going to direct this stuff
but my earlier everything that was
written prior to me directing my first
feature was for other directors to
direct you know because I've never had
the desire to ever ever direct the film
until I actually got on a set for the
first time and I was like oh this is
what this is this is what I'm passionate
about were you were you nervous or you
just didn't want to have that
responsibility of directing and managing
50 things at once well the first when I
first got on a film set days leading up
to directly I was definitely nervous but
it wasn't because I didn't want to
manage it was because I was I didn't
have the confidence because I didn't
know why I was doing so that was that
insecurity of not knowing what I was
doing
so it we had all those things going on
you know I was I was insecure I was I
was I don't have the confidence that I
have now because I didn't know what I
was doing
but it's you know and this was like this
has been quite a few films whereas you
know
took a while for me to get the
confidence to be able to actually deal
with actors the confidence to do with
know how to set up do my shot lists and
all that kind of stuff so this was over
a period of time it was just I didn't
just direct my first film did my second
film I knew it this was again like for
me it was going through film scope every
project is going to film school and so
but it was it was as I was learning my
confort I was building my confidence up
at the same time because again if you
don't know if you don't know what you're
doing you're insecure about what you're
doing and I was very I wasn't secure in
as far as being a director because I
have the knowledge yeah of what I was
doing so but imagine you were secure
with sports you said earlier in the
interview she played with baseball and
basketball at this local park or
something so could you take that same
feeling of confidence to this because in
some ways it's similar I mean you're in
a big arena you're playing with a bunch
of people some are on your team maybe
some aren't and you know you're kind of
moving around there's a lot of moving
pieces yeah but uh so when we as a
relates to sports even as a cuz I played
a little league baseball which I wasn't
very good at baseball so when when when
I played I want to close friend I was
love Sean Dunston he was like the
shortstop for Chicago Cubs and I wanted
to play shortstop only because I saw it
you know I was like Sean doesn't a fan
and so when I got to Lille and I wanted
to play you know I want to play a little
bit David hit the ball like I don't know
about this so there was this Stila
insecurity because I wasn't a good
baseball player but now basketball was
different I was pretty good at
basketball and I also wrestled I was a
wrestler in high school and so I was
pretty good I was pretty good at
wrestling but even when I started
wrestling I mean I was losing you know
there was still that I had to get
that confidence to know that I can win
so when they came to my second year and
so like Walmart this is what my coach
did my wrestling coach did like my first
year I didn't go downstate I was because
I was my first year wrestling so I was
losing a lot but he took me down state
with the other US city champions so to
help me to see how as a wrestler but
that built my confidence up I was like I
can do this so the next Chuck I went our
placement city in the I thought out
place in cities on the next two years I
won downstate but that was I had to have
my confidence built you know and as a as
a as a filmmaker when I first hit that
set you know I wasn't sure of who I was
as a filmmaker it nervous that
nervousness because you know but at the
same time it was like okay I'm gonna do
it
me it's I wasn't afraid I overcame that
fear but I just needed more confidence
you know because I didn't have that
unlike the knowledge when once I started
to go and do it and do it more and doing
more and doing more instance give you an
example like you know like when a
fatherless tells his son to jump off the
porch and so he can catch him so in the
Sun you know he's hesitant at first so
he does at one time then the second time
is it become so natural for him to do it
so easy for him to do it because he has
that confidence that his father's gonna
catch him it was the same with me like
once I did it one time okay okay this is
I like this did a second time third time
fourth time in with each project I was
building my confidence up because i was
learning more and I was open to I was
open to again the constructive criticism
I was open to working with collaborating
and listening to people who knew more
than I do
and I hate to put the ego aside and say
okay I want to learn this oh this is
what I want to do so I didn't go on the
spin set with pride over the ego I went
on there because I knew this is
something I love and this is something
that I want it to learn you know so I
had put
that the other side you know and I had
to overcome that fear but that
confidence is I had to build my
confidence why is it important for you
to produce everything that you write so
I can control it not that I'm a control
freak but the thing is is that I have to
make sure that that again I can I
control the the rights to my project
because not only would I benefit from
owning my own content but my sons will
benefit and their children would benefit
you know so that's very important for me
is for you know for when I'm going that
my children and their children and their
children are eating off or benefiting
from the works that their grandfather
great-grandfather put in so I think that
as filmmakers we all should be aware
that this is very informal that we want
our children's grandchildren to say okay
my grand granddaddy or my grandmother
left me something that you know that uh
I could be proud of so that's why it's
important for me to produce walking true
control of the content then I'll put out
was your relationship with your
grandfather very strong yeah I mean is
that something that you remember and
then you want to sort of emulate or well
I owe my mother on my mom's side I
didn't know my grandfather and oh my
says it's tricky because on my on my
father's side I didn't know my
biological grandfather but I knew the
man who who married my grandma and I
didn't know that he wasn't my real
grandfather because to me well I suppose
my biological grandfather because to me
he you know he was you know he was there
and so I had a we had a like a great
relationship with my grandfather
Oh and again to me in a way we didn't
know that he wasn't our real grandfather
me I didn't know publisher my brother
since prior because I didn't I didn't
you know I didn't I didn't care but saw
but what my grandfather had a great
relationship with him you know so you
always kind of remember that and yeah
you want to be that to future generation
so I had I had a better relationship
relationship with my grandfather then my
my real father I didn't know my again on
my mom's side my grandfather passed
before I was you know if I was born so I
didn't know him at all
so was he someone that was would instill
confidence in you and no my grandfather
no so because I think my father this is
I think my mom says all the time I
remind her and all of our children I
remind her most of my father my father
passed away two years ago of cancer but
he he was he was always my father every
time I remember my father he always did
something for himself he always worked
for himself and when he passed he left
you know he left farm for his children
so we have a farm in Michigan so he left
something for us you know to you know
that's why we have that I tell my
brother says all we have to keep his
name because he put a lot of work into
this life so much I never remember my
father ever working for anyone
you always work for himself you know so
I think I got a lot of that from him is
the fact that you know I had to work for
myself you know so my father even though
he wasn't technically in my life like
you know but he was a great influence on
me as far as doing what I needed to do
as a entrepreneur and as a businessman
and as a filmmaker he was a great
influence but you know he was great
influence yeah so even though maybe you
didn't see him get up at 4:00 in the
morning or wherever it was you just knew
that he he had that work ethic in him
obviously yes he was he was he was his
old man like my father was like he was
his home heating you know he was an
independent man you know he he did I
don't know what kind of work he did but
I know that he he always you know he
always he worked he did he did for
himself you know he always had a
beautiful
he always you know he always drove a
nice car
yeah but I always I don't I never
remember him ever going to work or
working for some he always worked for
himself and asked me more that's like
what did he do you know what did he do
you know for a living so you know he my
father did his thing but his
independence that he had the freedom
that he had is what I admired most about
him you know he could easily work for
the Chicago the post office or something
like that you know he wasn't even in
what's in the military he was a Miller
it was in the Air Force
so you know those jobs being here he
easily came out and worked the job but
he's like you know I'm going to be
independent man I'm gonna have my
freedom and that's what I might
I am I most about my father is the fact
that you know is there and that I think
taught me a lot just from looking for
off you know to do you to want to do
something for myself
yeah it's interesting when we look back
on our lives and see like oh yeah like
this person that I saw whether I had a
good relationship or whatever it was or
even if I knew them well that I wanted
to emulate something about them that I
really admired you know yeah it is
interesting I remember I was my mom my
mom and my father divorced when I was 7
years old so when they divorce you know
you want like my father was like you
know he was he was in my life for and I
remember I remember because he had a
drinking problem too but I remember I
remember I was about six years old or
seven years old the day he stopped
drinking I know exactly where we were at
the last time I ever saw him get drunk
again so we were walking through an
alley and I clearly remember I was like
semi market to alley and he we had when
we went to the liquor store he bought
some liquor and then walking through the
alley like in Inglewood and he just
threw the bottle down and I'd never see
him ever ever take a drink after that
and so when they the
voiced my parents divorced okay again
you know that was my father and I was
pretty upset you know I was pretty mad
at him and it was I was thinking about
sixth grade and I had wrote him this
long letter
that's why smart you know as far as how
I'm disappointed in you know you love me
and you're not in my life and so he came
over and you know we had a conversation
you know I was like you know you came
over here the conversation you know so
you know but after that time like you
know my father's you know he's a all
right you know he's I marry him so much
you know even though he wasn't you know
he wasn't there with me growing up I
like you know but just seeing seeing the
his freedom his independence is it's you
know it's why I always like you know and
you know you know I love him for that
yeah okay that maybe make me cry and
that made me I think that has a lot to
do with me and it's interesting because
when I started making movies he was
proud yeah he would he would he would
call the people my son baby no he was he
was he was very proud of that
so you know and in my sister my sister
says she's like because my sister my
father very close they were very close
like very close but I think that because
he was so proud of me
making movies is like she's like he
always Boston about you making movies
and stuff like that but you know it's a
great thing yeah my father's gonna have
to do a mascara
yeah have you ever had any near-death
experience Oh
my sister doesn't remember this but I do
she doesn't know about you tell us they
were telling and I remind her about it
cuz my [ __ ] my brother was a police
officer he had guns but they were all
illegal and we were very young
this was like oh oh oh I think I was in
maybe like the seventh grade right and
she swears she doesn't remember this so
we were all of my brothers were because
my brother had like the big screen TV
and I will go down and we go inside his
room and we watched like again the JA
use film did all of my films and and
like when I remember watching and one of
the things I really like stuck to me was
one of my favorite films office in and
gentlemen and I think we were watching
office in gentleman at night and and my
sister was playing with my brother's
gone and she was cop I choose point that
point at me and it didn't go off and she
pointed to the side in the window what
she said she doesn't remember that Coco
Coco Coco she said I don't remember that
ass a year she's pointing on but didn't
go off so I think that's the only time
other than not if that's considered a
near-death experience I don't know maybe
you know but other than that I don't I
don't ever recall having any near-death
experiences at all yeah thank God thank
God I didn't get shot
well yeah muscles I love my sister yeah
that's nice like you sound like you
really have a close family
yeah well we're not as close as like I'm
more close to what my sister named my
older brothers but like me my sisters
are very close like like when I will
even wait like she was so close with my
father and like my father you know like
when he had a drinking problem and there
were things he would do and nothing like
abusive he was never he never abused
I don't even think my father ever he I
don't ever remember ever saying whoever
with us at all
he was not an abusive man even when he
was he would get drunk he was never
abusive but he was like there was one
time my sister she tells me that he came
he took us made my sister we were on the
news and he took us to this graveyard my
mother say he would call her up I said
what are you gonna do and but my sister
and she didn't you know he would take me
because you know I love candy and he
became me my sisters like you back to
eating that candy but and then they say
he's gonna kill us and I like oh my god
so my sister's always been there like as
the like you know she's always been a
big sister like always like mad she
calls me up and always been a big
supporter like whenever a film come out
she's one of the first ones to buy the
movies whenever I need a movie I want to
see a movie I go over to her place and
she has all of my movies so she's been a
very big supporter of my fam Korea yeah
do you think that's why you like to do
movies about sort of people's lives and
and even even the best of families can
have you know squabbles or whatever you
think that's why you're attracted that
and not something that's more like
violent or yeah I think honestly I think
that the reason I'm attracted to the
stories that I write has a lot to do
with the movies that I were raised
raised on again like I don't know how I
can stress that you know I was like a
big John Hughes fan and I just like I
would outweigh to watch his movies like
breakfast campout breakfast kind of
Breakfast Club and I was just watching
movies and just falling over his movies
you know and watching the Spike Lee
movies and watching Charles back just
watching these movies and I knew that
that even like the old the old Dolomites
movies they were like pimp movies but
they were even in these pimp movies they
were a moral to the story so I knew that
you can all you can do these films
and people can love these films and they
don't have to have these negative images
and I'm sure that in growing up I'm sure
that growing up and growing up in the
community that I grew up in because now
the community that is known as Inglewood
was totally different when I was growing
up like when I was growing up everybody
on my on the block that we live on we
all like even today you know we all
consider - we all call ourselves cousins
and stuff like that we're not
blood-related but we all grew up on in
the same community but we were just all
clothes so those type of things
definitely got an influence on me you
know so it's so many things got it but
those things just grown up in that type
of environment where you know we would
love there like people like on our block
even though we were not blood-related
the resister still this strong type of
love so that's something that you know
molded me over the years you know and
know that you know as a you know as a
filmmaker the worst type of things are
those type of moments in history are
very important to me and it's like a
checkmate like I have to make sure that
I'm conscious us as far as conscious the
fact that I know that the the images
that you know I have to put out the more
positive images and stuff like that
because that is that's what I was
growing up that's what I witnessed you
know and it's interesting because at one
particular point it was I growing up it
was odd to see a single-family home like
you know in my community was like you
know everywhere everybody was married so
it was odd to see you know a woman who
lived who didn't have who didn't have a
husband and so those are the images that
I saw grown up you know those are the
images that I you know I want to portray
how long do you typically spend on a
screenplay when I it depends on the like
if it's a romantic comedy then what I do
is I would give myself two weeks that's
just for a first draft and once that
first draft is done then I'm always
tweaking even up to the day that we
shoot even if if we go on on set and
something that doesn't feel right with
the scene and I'm going to tweet that
saying but I don't give myself a certain
amount of time to say okay well I do get
my search of myself a certain amount of
time that's when I'm going to get pitch
the screenplay when I have one stuff but
that's normally taste two weeks but it
depends with a romantic comedy so I have
other screenplays like in the action
project or a couple of those that I
spent a little bit more time with maybe
three or four months just researching
and writing and doing things like that
but a romantic comedy very something
very easy for me to write and those two
weeks knock it out of two weeks and then
you know send it out and for feedback
and then who are you sending it to for
feedback so I have about four or five
people who are a couple of producers for
instant a couple of artist friends of
mine who actually read it first and give
me feedback on it yeah so they're
trusted people you know they're not
gonna be too nice but they're not gonna
be brutal if they don't need to be yeah
but I want them to be brutal yeah so I
have a guy who's a producer here in LA I
send it to him he reads it he gives me
feedback but I tell him I'm out I need I
need for you to be brutal you know oh
yeah so yeah and these are people who
the two young ladies are sending to
their screenwriters oh yeah so but if
they're not in the industry I don't I
don't send it because they don't really
know don't understand what they're
reading you know but they have to be in
the industry in order for me to like
stand out because if you're not in the
industry I think it's kind of
you remember what you you know meaning
that in the industry meaning they they
understand screenwriting they understand
though they even actor with the long
list of credits and they understand like
how ice cream ice cream place should be
formatted the different beats the
different turning points they have to
understand the whole structure of the
screenplay so I just don't just send out
is just anybody but these are my people
our trust and say okay they're gonna
give me this feedback to make this
project better when you say two weeks
does that mean like from the very first
sort of kernel of the idea - all the way
to the end or yeah absolutely
here's why because even before I write
anything I'm I'm thinking about the
screenplay from the beginning to the end
and thinking about thinking about
thinking about it and then once I do the
outline I make sure like when I do my
outline so I say you know the first
thing and I do minute it's like imma
have this out like this for two minutes
or this for three minutes the scenes I
put minutes next to the scenes so I know
that for this particular scene this
scene has to be two minutes this thing
has to be three minutes but no they once
I write there the the first draft then
it's like - about about two weeks - yeah
but once I have the outline and I start
on the script and give myself two weeks
and say I'll come a-knockin out in two
weeks what do you think is your biggest
accomplishment so far in your career so
my biggest accomplishment in my field
making career is there are so many there
are so many negative images that we put
out as black people as far as in music
industry in the film industry there's so
many negative image so many negative
images and I think my biggest
accomplishment is put out more positive
images and images that I have put out
meaning this seeming like people more
working and and you see the family unit
you see black men actually being
positive doing something for themselves
so those images those positive images to
me that were that's worth any
because at the end of the day is that
when people see those images and again
like I get so many emails from people
from all walks of life just thanking me
for putting out more positive content
and that's and just putting out more
positive content in this world you know
that's worth more to me than anything at
all like I cannot get again I can make a
film for ten thousand dollars but I'll
put them positive images out those
imported me and they're important to me
because of this like we already know we
already here like most people most
people even black people are afraid to
walk down any black community you know
because I had asked the question on my
on my social media page how many people
would walk down the Inga community and
most people black people said no they
would not go into the English community
after I've done workshops free workshops
they would not come into the English
community because of the negative images
so if people are justified people people
say that they're concerned for their
lives and they have the right to me so I
think that once we put out what positive
images then we can change it by change
by changing the images and by changing
the condition of of black America
meaning that the black community where
it can be safe it could be a safe place
to live I think that we could change the
scope of America
totally change the scope of America
because our communities you know we talk
about the violence in our community
right we think we know when you talk
about the violence and in America nine
times out of ten we're dealing with the
violence is going on in a black
and there's a reason for that is there's
a reason for it so for me is by changing
these images you know you see people who
look at these images okay
I haven't thought about it like this you
know now you see people who can only own
businesses I see people who can you know
walk through community like for me but I
can privilege was like a community night
one lady said today she said I really
enjoyed the fact that you I said you see
the children where our plan those images
are important to me because when I was
growing up you had children who can go
out and play nowadays in Chicago and she
called a a one year younger girl was
shot this happened like three or four
days ago now that young girl is is what
this woman my second marriage my first
my first wife brothers granddaughter
that's how close it is but she was shot
and so and I talked to my ex-wife about
a couple of days ago and she may not
make it so but we had only on the we
hear these these children being killed
in a black community so how do we stop
this so again I think we talked about
nothing but we talked about how what
China now is a superpower but one of the
things that they did to change the
condition of the Chinese people to make
them a great people that they are today
was they put their artist together and
they say okay we're gonna put out more
positive images so for me putting out
more positive images not only not only
correct the condition of the black
community but it corrects the condition
of America as a whole where people not
afraid to come to America because
America because of the violence that's
in America you know and so that's
important to me you know very very
important to me because we can weaken we
can definitely change change this
country for for the
without having to quote unquote you know
build a wall that's how I want to see
the entire world I want to see a world
where people children period can walk
down the street you women can walk down
she gotta be harassed
a world where is that we can no matter
where you are that you know there's no
reason here's the thing there's no
reason why I Mexican brothers and
sisters of in Mexico or we should even
be talking about war or they trying to
come over to America for a better way
people should be able to you know and
wanted to come to America it should be
coming over as a tourist just like we go
to different country as we should have
to go to different countries for a job
you know we should go be able to go
there you know just to relax just to you
know you know if you want to come okay
we we wanna we go there okay to live but
not just to survive people should be
able to stay in you know to live in
their culture where they can make that
details I'm sure hmm oh I'm sure they
all prefer to live in their country and
make a decent living that's just natural
so there shouldn't be a reason why
people have to go to other countries to
make a livin where there's enough wealth
in this world where we can take there
all human beings right regardless of
race class all human beings can live a
decent a safe strong life and that's the
world I want to see I want to see I want
to see a world where we don't even be
talking don't even have to be talking
about building a wall because I'm asking
brothers and sisters in Mexico or not
just said you know make our businesses
in the Africa are building assistance in
one of the country that you in that you
don't have to come you don't have to be
with with the master okay I want to come
to America for a better way of life
because in your country you do have a
better way of life and everyone deserves
a better way of life no matter where you
are in his word you deserve to live you
deserve to live a good life and that's
that's what I want to do and so my
greatest accomplishment is to show
particularly cuz as a black man black
people in a positive image but that's
never I'm never you never gonna catch me
showing anybody regardless of who they
are in a negative image at all so
whenever I do characters about my Latino
billing system we got so Hawaii people I
always like even when a black in
prevalence when I did the character
about this got a big pop up I sat down
with David Crawford make sure that who's
the white guy in the film you know to
make sure that these images are not
making the white community look bad or
these images are not know when I did do
films and I have Latinos in it make sure
that these images are not making the
Latinos look bad so this very this very
important to me you know I don't want to
put out that negative energy at all so
that's that's been my greatest
accomplishment and that's better for me
than winning an Oscar but whether
anything is the images that we put out
to the world it's interesting when
people you were saying about like
pointing a finger and other people or
whatever but it's interesting when
people point within their own community
mm-hmm whichever community it is and say
I want to fix this problem or I don't
like some of the stereotypes or I don't
like how we're turning on each other
mm-hmm you know do you think sometimes
people get rubbed the wrong way when you
try to address that absolutely just like
yesterday again I think I was telling
you yesterday I was talking to this
young lady and she was saying that she
pulled me to the side she was like look
this project refers to black and
privilege it was difficult for me to
watch you know and I said why she said
because it's difficult when you have to
look at yourself and examine yourself is
difficult and uh
and so whenever you have to again like
you know it's easier it's easier for us
to like for people period to point the
finger and say okay this is why such as
it's going on instead of just looking in
the mirror and dealing with the evil
within so it's easier to to point the
finger because most of us don't like to
exam itself so when she said that I'm
like you know she said but it needs to
be dealt with we need to talk about it
so this is what we do with blocking
privilege is that what we do is we don't
we don't point the fingers I had nobody
because you have to cool we have to
correct our own issues right we have to
deal with our own issues and how do we
do that so there's a scene where the guy
goes out the morning the main character
goes out because the people moving into
the from the projects moving to the the
community this driving black community
and now you see all this trash on on the
ground so he goes out with a paper bag
he starts to pick the trash up so are we
waiting for someone else to come and
pick the trash up or are we going to
just say okay if there's trash on your
street on your block you can't depend on
the city to come and pick that treasure
it's just as simple as that
pick the trash up you know and so that's
what the project is about is about it's
about examining self incorrectly self
and so our communities communities can
be safe and decent like we all should
like this is this is just this a humor
it's not that is a human privilege it
does have to do it another thing too is
that I know we we talk about you said a
lot of things people talk about white
privilege right and I know people made
disagreement with disagree with me on
this is the fact that why should we ask
anybody to give up their privilege
like I like I don't think we have a
right to ask anybody to give up their
privilege because we just have to every
human being like every human beings like
should be like like to go out and walk
down a decent neighborhood a safe
neighborhood to have your community to
be economically strong
that's a doesn't like a privilege and
that's something that we don't want to
take away from other people like like
you have that right
you have that right to live in a decent
neighborhood you have that right to live
in a clean neighborhood to live in a
economically strong neighborhood and
nobody have the right to take that that
privilege away from you just create your
own privilege within your neighborhood
to make us strong to make a decent - so
your children are choices can walk down
the street I wouldn't make a walk down
the street you'll see guys hanging out
on the street nobody should be nobody
should be asked to give up their
privilege for anything at all you know
that you know so that's my thing on that
that's my take on it and there's anybody
criticize - on the movie from within the
community because they felt that
something wasn't portrayed right or you
were making a statement or something and
they felt angry and you were surprised
absolutely last night so last night I
was sitting I was sitting in a and I was
sitting in the front but the lady in the
back of me she didn't I was a director I
don't like the way he's betraying us I
don't like it and other lady was like
you have to they were they were having a
comment so these are the conversations
that I want so late I look like I don't
I just don't like the way it's negative
Delaney the other day was like well you
have to see what the guy is talking
about what the movie is talking about
just look look at the messages that's
opinion the other ladies like so doing
the Q&A Delaney who whose is like I
don't like it she got up as she left so
yeah so I mean because it's hard to it's
what I'm telling this is very hard to to
look at an exam itself it's like the
most difficult thing so is these like
even
filmmakers right so as filmmakers we can
say like you have a lot of filmmakers
say well they don't want to do anything
but upset with Hollywood because they
can't because they don't want to because
they they're not making films so they
put the blame place the blame on
Hollywood they say then I it's this
whole this whole thing Illuminati and
said that you know there's the
Illuminati one allowed me to make movies
now man you won't make movie you know so
so it's easy to blame things on the
Illuminati or to say the reason why
certain people are successful in the
business because they're doing certain
things I saw them get the sign yes many
of these people just work hard you know
they did something they didn't didn't go
in with the mindset of I can't do it
because unless I sell my soul you know
so but it's easier to say those type of
things when you feel that your our
careers are not progressing the way we
feel like they are so it's easy to say
it's the lumati living on Illuminati
that's not a saying okay maybe I'm just
not projecting my mind to do maybe maybe
it's those thoughts because you know the
subliminal the the the subconscious man
is very important it's very powerful so
if you think think that the only way you
can be rich or the only way you can be
successful or do this is because you all
you have to say or so then you never
want to be successful you know I'm going
to be rich because you feel that in
order to get these things I have to
sacrifice something I have to sacrifice
my soul no you don't have to you can be
wealthy you can be rich you can be
successful and still keep your morale of
the moral fabric of who you are as a
human being but we we give our
subconscious mind this these commands
when we don't have to I mean we have to
just know that we can be successful
regardless of what yeah we know there's
xenophobia which is fear
I forgot what the term is for fear of
people within your own group so to speak
but it is really interesting to examine
that whatever whoever your group is
whether it's in church or college or
your neighborhood or street-racing um
but it's just interesting because I
think that's like a taboo topic because
it's like well no we're supposed to but
when there's issues within the group
with everybody whoever they are
and there's stereotypes that certain
people are supposed to live up to I'm
more referring to my own situation but
it makes people very angry and and and
it's it's it's very taboo to kind of
talk about that and you know I applaud
you for I haven't seen the film but I
applaud you for doing that because you
know you are gonna rattle people
whatever it is when you talk about your
own neighborhood or whatever it is and
you and you challenge stereotypes oh
yeah
one of the things that a couple of
audience members said yesterday that one
guy said he's that man he said I'm just
stunned I really don't know what to say
he said I mean he said this is needed
he said but I just don't know I don't
know what the evenings like I don't know
what to say but I know this is needed
you know I'm like it is needed I mean I
know it's cuz it's me and I want us to
be like completely silent well watching
this fan I'm like okay I'm like what's
going on it's like silence because
people are thinking people are thinking
and people are enough guests and I've
seen some people get up and walk out
because it's difficult it's this is
difficult - again it's difficult to like
to look at self so you know they got up
and walked out it was like you know it's
nothing you can do about that he does
nothing to do but as long as as long as
we placed the blame others and not do
self critique or look at self then we
can never get out of the condition that
we have because we're always pointing
finger
I started just say okay this is what I'm
gonna do to correct the issues in our
community and people like no one wants
to see like what human being wants to
see it a one your child is kill no one
wants to see that people want to see
like people want to see it community all
communities I'm sure decent safe people
want to see that you know so that's just
that's just my take on babies do you are
you gonna do a volume - yes okay
just already are in the works oh well I
started out line it and this one oh yeah
I'm definitely do Bob